three
two
what is all
people of the universe
it is friday
september 9th
2022 and by the way it's supposed to
rain here in l.a i know that's kind of
crazy
very weird because it's super hot right
now outside yeah so apparently in the
next hour or two it's gonna go from 95
to 75
and start raining which god bless i'm
here for it you know
but anyway happy friday everybody
our we have a new partner announcing
gamer stuff let's go
supply me daddy
this is great i've been wanting an
energy drink flavor lemon limeade and
gamer sup we're gamers up nation cheers
what do you got there yolo emotional
damn i got emotional damage
like it will cure my damage
oh it's not giving the damage
we love that okay
sure
oh it's like a fruit punchy
love that red kool-aid vibes
you know
i'm just so happy to be working with
gamer sup and it's not even the
copyright but i just want to get this
offer they're doing is insane i'm just
saying this for love of the game
if you go to
gamersups.ggh3 you get a free sample
pack you don't even have to put in a
credit card they just straight and free
shipping you just straight get to try it
for free that's gamer sub nation
also thank you to native
for sponsoring us
yes baby
all right we got a great show here for
you guys
oh
hold up
[Music]
announcement buckingham palace has
announced the death of her majesty queen
elizabeth ii
[Music]
announcement buckingham palace has
announced the death of that needs to be
part of the drama
techno song i could see it drop into it
ryan
yo we regret to inform you
an important announcement buckingham
[Music]
oh wow unfortunately guys what are we
doing
i regret to inform you all that uh her
magazine
queen elizabeth the third or whatever
number she's the second one i think
has regrettably passed away and who
could have seen this coming at the young
age of 96
why do the good always die young right
man taking too soon too soon too soon
too
too soon gone this is of course a joke
of uh when her husband died the dear
prince philip phillip
uh what is the joke i don't even know
okay so
i'll show you when prince philip died
yeah there was like a techno going on it
was on like bbc hits one radio yeah and
then we have that here that was radio
one uh the only thing is um it's it's a
real radio station so it's probably
copyright the music okay i'll just mute
it just so you can see the joke but
that's that's what we're doing here
we are going to be talking about queen
elizabeth i know uh some of y'all here
there it is
they just
i see this was actually super viral
that's five million views wow hit it for
a second this is a party thing all right
[Music]
buckingham palace has announced the
death of his royal highness the duke of
edinburgh
like doesn't even miss the beat
it keeps going baby an important
announcement buckingham palace has
announced the death of her majesty queen
elizabeth ii
[Music]
yeah so
we had some emails from uh beloved fans
of ours saying
i know you guys are probably thinking
about goofing on the queen
but please do not i please respect her
please don't for love of god i'll just
say this
as respectful as we possibly can be yes
we do have a coffin can you cut to it
yeah
we do have a coffin
and we are planning
some skags to play with her cadaver
and to send her off in a in the regal
way that she deserves
yes
sam is uh
we have a bunch of beans we were gonna
send her off with i don't know if you
could see sam but we'll deal with that
later but i wanted to say
to our english fans
who are mourning the loss of the queen
and take uh take that with a great
reverence i would just warn you to
probably just skip that segment
[Music]
with peace and love
to our
english
wonderful super troopers
i am saying with peace enough please
skip that segment
i don't want to hear anyone complaining
okay just skip the segment okay we'll
give up not your idea we're gonna give a
fair warning
we're gonna say we'll warn you before
and after we'll say we're done
so those in mourning right now i'm just
gonna tell you
i'll let you know before we pour the
beans into our coffin
[Music]
we have all kinds of other
relics there we're going to send her off
right
we actually have the corpse of one of
her butlers interestingly
that we're going to bury her with yeah
we got we got that
so irish did the ir the irish are happy
the irish are happy she died huh it's
pretty wild
or is it wild
not that wild considering the history
the irish be tap dancing on her grave
doing that iris jig bruh
no no but um so anyway that's coming up
so to my english brothers and sisters
out there
we will give you this is the this is
what's going on ireland right now
the queen is dead
[Music]
yeah
for the irish keep watching obviously
yeah
man so
we've got that going on kefl's um
who has been a huge story lately i don't
know if you guys know her she's a twitch
streamer political commentary
has gone to war with kiwi farms
and actually seemingly won
kiwi farms for those of you don't know
is one of the worst places on earth it's
a website dedicated to harassing doxxing
white supremacy
anti-semitism
transphobia homophobia they're basically
the worst people in the world
the jews and well you know them too i
guess i did say anti-semitism
lol this gamer sub
has caffeine in it
oh it's so good
i'm doing a strawberry lemonade and i
got
uh you got that waifu i did the white
food cup i had to do it
look at that and the pink of the
lemonade it turns her
i got a pink-haired waifu what more
could you ask right what more could you
ask for i got a guacamole gamer fart
9000.
wow really what it's called seriously
well how does it taste it's actually
really good
it's my favorite one so far i've had
three of them you you said guacamole
guacamole gamer fart juice nine thousand
nine thousand okay
we've also got um
um
wow this queen segment's long yeah also
hey gabe one sec there's also this huge
drama i don't know if you guys knew
about the don't worry darling drama with
harry styles chris pine
shia labeouf we've prepared a
powerpoint presentation to get you guys
through what has become
probably one of the most complicated t
drama events
of the decade
so we're gonna walk you guys through
that frame by frame
we got a lot going on here today gabe
talk to me hey you do hey
how are you doing well i'm not good
not good why what happened oh yeah the
queen just died right i know it's just
very sad but disappointed yeah so
sorry it is very sad
is that hitting you is that hitting you
hard gabe
what's hitting all of us the grandma of
american and british
that's like a grandma it's like that
grandma died you felt so sad where are
you mourning right now
i'm at a um
i'm at a pizzeria mulberry pizzeria
[Laughter]
yeah i can tell i felt better
yeah
i mean i'm just like you of when i'm sad
i want a pizza so right
i'm not judging
did you say you have english family or
did you just say that she feels like
your grandma
she kind of feels like like america's
grandma that's what i'd say right okay
interesting interesting and how are you
guys observing her memory i guess
i guess i guess
comes around everybody cheers for us
like everybody's like a fan of queen
elizabeth ii really everyone in the
family
yeah
wow that's so fascinating and what was
your favorite thing what was your
favorite thing about queen elizabeth
well kind of like that charm you know
like america's grandma you know
everything
that's my
thing
what's your favorite memory of queen
elizabeth
well i don't really met her so i can't
believe
have a memory i just i just saw her on
tv and
she's charming that's about it
she's charming that one
all right well it's friday baby
it's friday
let me ask you this it's friday baby
what kind of pizza did you order
i had a pepperoni slice and okay a
couple of wings
okay whoa
oh you went to vegas last weekend right
how was that did you go end up getting
any uh prostitutes did that work out
i'm not not prostitute
i thought you said you were going to do
that
would you like something clean
would you admit to it if you did here uh
on the show
i probably would
you would i gotta be honest yeah you're
honest man but i don't want to get in
trouble
right
get in trouble with it you won't get in
trouble for that yeah yeah
who would be mad at you if they knew
that you saw a prostitute
i don't know somebody or it could be
someone's girl you don't know yeah yeah
okay there's a lot to insult to ask
someone's girl
any plans this weekend
how you doing what are you doing [ __ ] my
[ __ ] [ __ ] boy baby
gamer sup in my ass [ __ ]
look at my ass
what you doing this weekend
we're to have a we're going to have a
fight and we're going to have some
a fight on tv um
tomorrow night
all right have some best guess
all right i'm not am i not allowed to
curse on tick tock live
it's not consistent but you never know
they keep it tight sister snipers are
looking at you yeah they keep it i'm
live
you don't want to get
you don't want to get like you know you
don't want to get a community guided
violation and then they shadow ban you
and all the views go down and stuff no
we don't want that no
all right well this is a message to my
tick tock audience [ __ ] my [ __ ]
[ __ ] boy baby
it's friday
there you go check positive it's friday
baby
pissing my
vehicle [ __ ]
[ __ ] in my ass and then poop it back in
my ass baby
you think when queen elizabeth died did
she [ __ ] herself because that's normally
what happens right no that is normal she
almost certainly did
what oh really yeah maybe yeah everyone
shits when they die
why did i not know that's because the
body the sphincter muscle relaxes yeah
well it all comes flowing out and you
[ __ ] and piss yourself
would think like well she's the queen
she's not going to [ __ ] herself but she
did no she did
she's human
to be realistic at 96 she was probably
[ __ ] herself
yeah that's probably pretty loose as
it is well you don't want to go to
heaven constipated you know yeah you
give that [ __ ] out on earth yeah that's
embarrassing
well
they don't have a bathroom in half of
them
yeah i don't think i don't think they do
i don't think they do if there's no
bathrooms in heaven
hell is actually heaven there's just
[ __ ] lining the streets
everybody's pooping in my body i'm
[ __ ] my pants
yeah all right buddy well listen um
you know there is a thing called fecal
transfusion so that you can actually
have someone [ __ ] in your ass like
that's actually a thing
have you heard about that gabe fecal
transfusion i never
i never heard of it but yes so
some people have gut problems
where they're don't have enough healthy
bacteria
and they'll take the [ __ ] from a healthy
person
and inject it into
that person's ass it's called a fecal
transfusion so [ __ ] in my ass is
actually a somewhat
realistic uh request clinical
medical yeah definitely medical
someone said it in the chat that when
the queen died and [ __ ] herself that's
called a royal flush
very very good
that was a good one yes so
yeah i wonder what a fecal transplant
from the queen would be like though
human fecal matter what's good or what
interesting
all right gabe you take care okay you
have a good weekend
try not to try not to be too heartbroken
over the queen okay it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be fine
is that what you said when the queen
died
no no not like that i say goodbye
goodbye
baby
if you could say
if if if the queen was in her royal
coffin being lowered into the ground and
they said gabe please say some words for
the queen what would you say
i'd say sparewalk grandma
well that's wholesome
[Applause]
and have a great weekend okay
all right
you too
[Applause]
yes sir an important announcement
buckingham palace has announced the
death of her majesty queen elizabeth ii
[Music]
it's kind of giving me
david
vibes yeah shout out to the family yeah
[Music]
an important announcement buckingham
palace has announced the death of her
majesty queen elizabeth ii
love looks actually sad
love are you sad
no
no
no i'm not sad about it honestly
now carl gustav were to pass yeah then i
would be very surprised that
no i would have to take uh
probably a week off from that yeah if
your king died
yeah yeah
no
are you serious or no i'm just i'm
actually curious
i'm joking i'm joking
but would you miss your king if you died
well i i think our our royal family is
not as bad as the uk one they're not
like
p words and [ __ ] oh that's good that's
good at least
that you know
you know
no no not sweden
yeah okay well not everyone is corrupt
right well the best ones are the ones
that hide it you know i get i guess the
the monarchy by default is corrupt i
guess that's kind of the point
like the police
yeah but they haven't done your thing no
redeeming qualities it's too early for a
cab love yeah 202 earlier
all right let's move on with this uh
fantastic show we've got here today
can i just say yeah the last episode
with the diss tracks was just like
next level amazing
i i was driving home
and
i kept driving around in circles because
i didn't want to go inside the house i
just wanted to keep listening
and i was like you did i was dancing
like you were just now i was like that
in my car
it was awesome yeah i'm so glad that
people enjoyed that because
we're talking about our last episode we
had the ryan cavanaugh diss track
competition
and the entries were just incredible the
amount of talent on display just wow i
mean blown away yeah loved it and the
fans are loving it i'm just so glad you
guys are enjoying that and yeah i hope
you're checking out the artist by the
way who who participated
i know he was uh i was sad when he
didn't make it i was like oh that was i
thought he might win but it was close
man
it was jay fella and he was the other
guy everyone was writing for
uh
jake yeah somebody it was just jake it
was also a zazzle zazzle
i mean there were too many good ones
they were all good
sookie ended up winning of course so
shout out to did you guys get there i
loved dirt mountain yeah they emailed me
back by the way i loved that he
corrected you and you still stayed the
wrong way no he was kidding oh he was
kidding he said it's sucky i was like
really he said just oh yeah i think he
was just playing yeah okay
he's doing a little joke
we do a little trolling um
i love their mouth
their mouth yeah that was awesome you
know what's funny about dirt mouth he
claimed our [ __ ] well that was he
dropped it it was an accident it was
just funny don't i'm not trying to give
him hate he didn't do it on purpose but
yeah one of his songs we listened to i
guess was entered into animated um
copyright thing and our [ __ ] whole
episode got claimed
from dirt mouth yes he was actually he
dropped it though it's all good
extremely apologetic
yeah it's funny by the way all the songs
are up on the highlight
oh all the songs are up on the
highlights channel so that's a good
important thing to know um
yeah jay fella i personally thought
and he left a comment
and i was like oh where
left one he's what was the comment you
guys have yeah i'll find it in one sec
we said he was like a 40 year old dad
who just does this like for fun which is
crazy because yeah everybody was saying
he like his production sounded super
professional
he said so much fun appreciate the
support i'm just a four-year-old husband
and father when i got a chance to visit
something i love along with my favorite
podcast it was a win-win
so cool i thought he was going to make
it to the finals but
jay dillo went up against
some other
fella
okay you're right i don't know why i
keep saying hey fellas hey bella and
whatever but anyway
jay fella i'm sure we'll have another
opportunity to shine for you true uh
this is just the beginning
next up
uh we're going to have to do a brad the
bull tribute i think oh boy love the
there was a lot of motifs reoccurring
brad the ball was won
i love the lore
oh my god you know um
suki
the winner the winner really did have a
winner moment in there with the trisha
paytas just so good it's so good
every time i heard it it's like my brain
just says it in my head yeah because
also it's it rhymes yeah so you can't
help but but think it so good yeah it
was amazing yeah that was speaking of
trisha paytas she's been trending with
the queen because everyone this is like
the most overused joke at this point
because everyone's been saying on
twitter have you seen this hila
patricia's baby is gonna or the queen is
gonna be reincarnated as trish's baby
i mean it's pretty funny but i've heard
it like it's very funny but i've heard
it like 10 000 times
there was
there was a tweet with 650 000 likes
about it yeah
are you serious no i'm telling you her
name was trending yesterday it was like
200 000 tweets about the whole
queen thing
the timing is pretty interesting though
but she would have had to have the baby
right yeah so it didn't happen
there's no there's no in between the
soul goes directly into the newly born
yeah so it didn't happen
your laugh oh i you're laughing queen
elizabeth is about to be reincarnated as
trisha vedas baby and you're laughing oh
here's 630 000 oh my god me
[Music]
well i don't think as far as i know
trisha had the baby so queen uh
she's safe my wonderful queen you are
you are safe from that uh hell no i'm
just kidding
there's like three more with more than
300k likes too yeah they were all
getting just so
i don't think it's fair
you know the baby has done nothing we
love the baby
that we don't i shouldn't say i'm to say
something i don't i i probably shouldn't
say that baby's my nephew
that's right that's right you should be
hoping for the reincarnation you could
be
the aunt and uncle just saying that
maybe but no the baby yeah she'll get us
up it's family it's family stop it's
family stop all right next topic
family
family family i love my family
love my nephews all right we got a lot
to get to yes so let's get to it all
right so philly d's been talking mad
[ __ ] oh wait abs got another one for me
what is that
another uh
no let's go let's move on let's move on
wait you didn't even send it though he
did send it but it doesn't matter let's
move on where did you send it i'm
looking at discord i'm about to lose it
guys
he didn't send it he accidentally didn't
send it
real funny
huh philly g's been [ __ ] with me
i'm getting tired of this [ __ ] philip
defranco
when i said i'm not going oh here we put
up a highlight fitness progress post
dude
on twitter no he told me to go hiking i
knew this would happen and i said i'm
not going hiking and then he commented
some [ __ ] like oh the subreddit's going
to be mad at you now and of course the
subreddit there's like a post with 7 000
up votes if everyone like you need to go
hype game with philip defranco
so i said fine i'm gonna go hiking with
him and then he's swinging out this [ __ ]
don't worry i got you me and his his
[ __ ] baby pack and i'm like bro that
ain't weight if that ain't rated for my
weight okay
you couldn't dream of carrying me like
that
philly looks yolked man
looks yolked in that pic yeah he sure
does
wait so is that his photo or not
or what is this he's just okay it's just
a meme i don't know grandma either
i guess now he's just having a big joke
out of it
yeah so he's [ __ ] with me and it's
like man you i already set out going on
the hike bro just leave me alone damn
are you going to go on the highway i
said i would i mean i don't know i guess
not and not if what these shenanigans
keep up
you know
friendship with phil defranco's about to
end at this rate no never don't say that
no we're bros for life there's 1.5 000
people watching on tick tock why you
guys watching a tick tock go watch on
youtube
but
it's our home tick tock's our own
well your live won't take that tick tock
is not going how's the uh the podcast
one doing i wasn't able to go live i i
don't have the technology here oh i'm on
the podcast instagram
they said i get nervous every time ethan
looks over here
oh they can see you reacted
no they're saying you they they get
nervous when you just look over
oh that's gotta be a funny angle for
them um how many people are watching uh
right now we have uh 380.
okay it was just great
it was that it was at 800 so
either they left or they went to youtube
good we'd love to hear it
all right well philip defranco uh it's
on site man
shenanigans all right super mega here uh
supermega
these guys made a tiny stool for
there's some elas lander in the chat
listen you guys what are they saying
they're saying i'm controlling i'm not
controlling
this is a family issue that ethan and i
have an agreement on with multiple other
people wait people are accusing you of
being controlled because you don't want
me to talk about it ethan is just not
listening to our agreement by talking
about it so
um well to be fair you're the one who
conjured her name
yes right but that was in a very
non-profit
you know what i love my family
ela is not controlling ella's doing the
right thing trust me you guys
this is um
me looking out for a lot of other people
it's not just me involved here
and so
it's it's bigger than me
i wish the queen would be born in
trish's baby that would be so regal i
mean they just they're nothing but the
the best there you know all right thank
you wheeler now there's wheel is in the
chat area
so
they super mega had hassan on and they
gave his ass a little stool
well where's the tweet because that's
kind of where the beef started in it
let me look
i hate him i hate him a lot actually it
was terrible i hated this podcast
oh really don't want don't watch this
podcast
well anyway they did a nice funny little
gag on you here i know oh yeah real
funny we put some applause funny gag
well hold on
that's something good about it this is
what i got yep
we haven't had something made
specifically for a guest yet nope like a
piece of furniture dedicated to them
they got you a tiny tiny chair
it's like literally ankle level
it does like the the top of the chair
goes it's below your knee it might reach
the does it even reach the top of your
calf
no way no so they thought it would be
real funny to mess with my bestie hassan
and apparently something i said pissed
them off so they delivered something to
the office here
for me
and i don't even know why we accepted
this i'm not looking for more beefs from
these guys i'm like i have enough people
to hate me but now the supermega is out
to get me
and um did you find that tweet
yeah just send it in discord give a
little more context here
they've been calling me out on
twitter as well here let me show you
this and again they so insanely
disrespectful so here's this
matt watson's a friend of the show
actually i don't know
alex mcgee
is that his ryan
his last name is mcgee that's like a
fake name yeah you're just that's just
south carolina irish phobia right now
i'm just being real it's like oh
tits mcgee over here you know what i
mean like it's just a meme matt white
and i stand by that mcgee is not a real
surname it's like it's a it's a joke but
okay so apparently they're pissed at me
now
and i have another rival so bring out
the thing that you want me to do
okay
all right thanks
shredder knows you're okay
[Music]
all right thanks guys i got what is this
because i'm fat is that what's going on
triple wide yeah it's a triple wide
no you guys and it's got just on it just
on it bro i'm not calling you fat why'd
you do three together then the chair has
cushioning with the crocs yeah yeah it's
got it's got crocs that's true the
little crocs are a vibe for sure i even
died with those for you yeah you really
dazzled those yeah
well you said we didn't have a budget
yeah okay so very funny guys hahaha
there's something under the chair for
you there it is yeah
oh great there's a letter here [ __ ]
i didn't want this [ __ ] man i i just
tried to make a joke i mean
do you know how many beefs i have i
can't keep control of this okay to ethan
all right let's see what's inside this
envelope encrypted i'm just trying to
make fun of me coming at me
[Music]
[Laughter]
hand ty i mean it's typed you could even
write it out
okay
september 8 2022 ethan klein h3 podcast
okay dear ethan klein
aka h3h3 productions it's unsure as to
why you have decided to take it upon
yourself
oh i see what's going on here
take it upon yourself and your showdown
line attacks lander into fame super mega
and then i recognize
kavanaugh you guys aren't working with
him are you
i can't talk about it he funds
not only did you claim we forced a guest
to sit in the seat you also suggested
that the super mega cast does not have a
20 billion dollar studio budget
come on
i've seen the prop work you guys do okay
cut the ship while amusing and slightly
annoying at best i would advise you to
stop and mitigate your damages now
your toy podcast seems fun and all but
this is real business with real
consequences and you're causing real
damage that sounds very familiar i know
clearly you are very unhappy and
disturbed human to take it upon yourself
to attack our good name
ethan you have been warned and we will
not be threatened and maligned and stand
by idly you have until uh september 9th
is that that's today
that would be today well it says 12 p.m
so we've already passed the deadline
to remove all slander against us or
we'll be forced to pursue legal action
who acquired the h3 podcast
as well as the ethernet and election
govern yourself nathan i know the
channel
yeah why are they coming for that
and then they signed they said uh
sincerely matt watson
friend of the show wikipedia 4.9
out of 5. well not for long
and then alex tits mcgee
[Laughter]
wikifeed
5.3 out of 5. we're gonna have to do
something about that this is uh this is
outrageous five point three out of five
get the [ __ ] out of here all right
leave
get out
damn get out
get out thank you uh guys
it's kind of cute though they just
called me fat that's it they're just
calling me fat okay but you take a seat
you're still confused
[Music]
can you even see what it looks like
don't even i fit fine on one by the way
look how much space just for the record
well
just for the record i fit fine on one
dan i think you need to get an angle
from back here where i'm where i'm at a
little bit of spillage but i don't need
three chairs okay
look at show this though look at all the
free space over here look how much space
is over here bro
this is ridiculous
insulting
leighton what the [ __ ] did i say get out
of here dude i want to see you anymore
get the [ __ ] out god damn
all right i don't know what's up with
these guys but apparently they want the
smoke
so
will they have to sending them a cursed
stroller here pretty soon
[Music]
i'm gonna curse you guys you guys
started a war you do not want
to participate in
okay i've been doing wars like this
since before you guys were born
the chat is saying we could fit on it
together probably you could fit three
people there's three chairs i don't know
about three people maybe
hey you know what matt why don't you
chill the [ __ ] out before dad comes and
straighten your ass out like last time
oh no yeah that's right dad's a friend
of the show too okay and alex tits mcgee
whoever the [ __ ] you are
i don't know anything about you but
you've chosen to malign and attack me
we went through a war together i feel
like i i'm inclined to take a side man
all right you pay me i'm with you thank
you that's all i wanted to hear it's a
ryan tits mcgee actually
alex
he was fighting alex his name's alex
okay
seems alex that's the disrespect he gets
for this
yeah so super mega i don't know who they
are but
they're definitely going to hear from us
um
okay thanks i guess
why'd you even let leighton in i mean
he was here when we got here it was
weird
who let him in no that's what i'm saying
like we showed up in the morning and he
was just sitting in your chair and the
gate was closed yeah it was because
i don't know how you did that it's a
[ __ ] ninja
don't trust those guys over there
all right well
while uh
unimportant announcements buckingham
palace has announced the death hold on
her majesty queen elizabeth ii
hold on
i love that footage
i just watched cam have to look away
from his camera it's a jump scare you
got to give me a jump scare
songbird of our generation cam
[Music]
all right
rest in peace
did god save her in the end i i can't
god shout out to his family
they say god save the queen did he on
this day say no more
or did he sit or was she saved and
that's why she lived so long
that i i think the second one
[Music]
my queens of tick-tock
[Laughter]
i was listening to um
a report about the queen's death and
they went up to one of the guys in
england and they're like did you hear
the queen died and he's like no way
you're lying i was like man she's 96
nobody should be surprised that's a good
point
that's about the most expected thing
oh yeah you guys don't want to step to
this
the brawn and the brains that's right if
uh
if let's pnp can't do it i send dad in
to clean up right
go
so
so that's that eh so that's that um so
we are
already at 37 minutes and
we're a good deal behind on the uh
schedule so here's what we're going to
do we're going to thank our sponsors and
then we're going to get keflas
on the line to talk about this
incredible
kiwi farm saga
first i want to thank our brand new
partner oh my god it's gamer sup i am
stepping on this dipping on this thing
i'm sipping on this sup and i love it
oh by the way my flavor is the um
lemon lime did you try mine no good yeah
i also have the lemon limeade really
good i'm feeling good about it oh i like
it
i feel great and it's like energizing me
cameron you said you were wired i'm
sipping on the lychee right now i love
it i've been drinking all morning it
gives me more energy than i've had in a
long ass time no i like your shaker bro
you guys are juiced up you know you seem
pretty energized that's it i'm just
trying to [ __ ] jack bro and i noticed
when i took a sip you're almost done
with it that's it i'm thirsty and i'm
the design on my cup is so sick
it says drink me on her tits oh my god
oh my god
i'm blushing
i want cup that cups
gonna have to fight me for it yeah just
a huge shout out and thank you to our
new partner gamer sup
they're providing us beverages
keeping us energized
let me tell you about uh gg energy it's
zero sugar zero calories it's a healthy
alternative
to a traditional energy energy drinks or
soda like you know monster red bull coke
that kind of poison
it's most cost effective it's 35 cents
per serving on average one tub
equals 50 drinks from the store
this is the craziest thing you guys
you can try
gamer sup for free
with free shipping
you don't even have to put in a credit
card
[Music]
use h3 use the code h3
on their website gamersup.gg h3
and you just get put in your address and
boom they send you a free sample
no rest
try gg risk free no credit card info is
needed just a free sample baby all you
need is an email and a physical shipping
address
code h3 by the way will get you a
discount too if you're already gamer sub
nation
uh link in the description guys
go get that free sample you are not
going to regret it because i am sucked
up right now
love it gamer subs
gamer
subscribe thank you thank
and then finally
a big thank you to
native
this is a special deodorant
okay god i forgot to put deodorant today
smell it put this on look i still get it
no let me see how bad is it i don't
think it's bad let me smell it don't be
like okay
the coconut vanilla one if you're good
that's what this is it smells so good
so weird
i didn't smell anything i was just
expecting it i didn't know anything
i was just
ready for a facebook no i just i just
realized and i was like worried about
how they might go because i forgot i
know that feeling man yeah i know it all
too well
here's what's so cool about native okay
you've heard me talk about how much i
love native
and uh the thoughtful formulation behind
all their products
um
but
it's not just what's on the inside that
counts but also the outside native is
releasing their deodorant
that you know and love with new improved
plastic free packaging
really
native is doing their part to help the
earth with their 100 plastic free and
recyclable packaging
when you buy dude this smells so good
[Music]
what is that
coconut vanilla
oh my god bro you want to eat your pits
[Laughter]
why do they make it smell so good then
no i
know for real
i like the smell
yeah bro they have oh my god i was
telling sam about this earlier they have
limited edition flavors and they had one
that was wait did you call it return did
you refer to the deodorant flavor okay
is it flavor something you taste okay so
you're right you're right
um they had limited edition scents and
they had cherry blossom macaroon
and i've never smelled anything better
and maybe you use this this is your
go-to yeah i've been using this for a
while um regular deodorant uh has been
causing me to burn my arm burn so i've
been using this for a while now yeah
it's really good
uh native is part a proud partner of the
one percent for the planet we are
committing a one percent of the plastic
free deodorant sales to environmental
nonprofits just like all of natives
other deodorants their plastic free
deodorant is aluminum and paraben free
it kills odor causing bacteria it has 24
hour odor protection to keep you feeling
and smelling fresh
with native choose from 10 different
scents
including their classic
coconut vanilla sensitive formulas a lot
of people in the chat are saying they
already use it yep dang native taking
over i'm gonna take this home
i'm using all native products though
[Applause]
they have a sensitive formula formula of
uh without baking soda and even
unscented
so
are you ready to try plastic free
deodorant go to nade uh native
d-e-o
like deodorant deodorant native do dot
com slash after dark the links in the
description
or use the promo code after dark at
checkout and get 20 off your first order
that's
nativedeo.com or use the promo code
after dark at checkout for 20
off your first order native we're loving
it folks
thank you thank you with peace and love
yes
[Music]
all right so
as we prepare for this call with kaffels
i just want to give a little bit of
maybe we could just bring her on and we
could talk about it because she's i'm
sure she knows all this stuff ow uh sure
i mean she actually is in the waiting
room already so you want me to know i
just like pulled my hair back and it
like hurt ow
what do we do about it
nothing that's weird
what do we do about that did you damage
your hairline you think is the headlight
bro
[ __ ] dude
yeah we've got those super mega [ __ ] do
man they [ __ ] with your hair man
oh dan are you coming take a look yeah
right here is where it was hurting you
see anything whoa that's bright
you're good you're good look at my hair
thank god i don't know man all right
that's
the king this here's my money maker
folks i'm growing my hair back people
so kiwi farms just give you a little bit
of background here
it was founded in 2013 by this dude
joshua noel moon who was a former 8-chan
admin
and it was launched with the express
purpose of harassing
this person
christine chan
who
i don't know if you know anything about
about them that would take a whole
podcast again i mean they are
a real interesting person who ended up
going to jail for like
essaying his own mom right
or her she yeah
trey yeah so
anyway
they branched out from that and they
started targeting
i feel like they're equal opportunity i
feel like they just hate everybody but
they say the worst things it's like we
want you
to un-alive yourself
they are
just the most vile they had a page on me
that was like 500 pages long just it was
all just you know anti-semitism [ __ ]
like that hey you glanced i never looked
at it what'd you see there dan
i
i i i don't know uh what it said
uh in modern times i i remember i forget
exactly there was like a period where we
were getting
brigaded a lot and we were able to trace
it back to that website oh really yeah
and this was like three years ago or
something and
at that time
your page was maybe like a hundred
pages but then
as we were looking into the story um
i had heard from somebody that it had
ballooned to several hundred pages well
that's excellent
i'm a big boy over there but
i don't think
i don't think i need to be flattered
because it seems like every public
figure has a big ass insane
most people that were popular on the
internet had
to some degree um
yeah you certainly were not the biggest
target uh by any means
but i think anyone who has like any
kind of minority status or
some sensitive issue they just they'll
go they go after it like kefos is trans
they have a specific chip on the
shoulders it seems like against queer
and trans people i'm jewish
uh so that that that they targeted and
um
it's really incredible the site is full
of right-wing trolls doxxing swatting
and irl harassment
was not only condoned but encouraged by
the admins of the site
they even had a guide in regards to
harassing trans people it was calculated
psychotic
and designed to
inflict maximum pain i mean look at this
[ __ ]
this is the guy kiwi farms published
with regards to harassing trans people
pretty incredible they were saying use
their dead name
figure out who they're friends with
find their docs and post it
how is it okay for this website to even
exist like
yeah i don't know ultimately
i think
it's kind of a loophole because websites
that host content aren't responsible
from some legal doctrine uh for the
posters
and if he's protecting their so there
was actually an incident in new zealand
the christ church shooting yeah that's
the guy who live streamed it and went
into a mosque
yeah
and they kept reposting the video there
and the gov the new zealand government
said yo you got to take this [ __ ] down.
and also we want the name of the people
who's posting us and they said we're not
going to give you the name [ __ ] you blah
blah they went on this whole thing and
so they got banned in the whole country
of new zealand oh okay
so they've also actually actually
they've driven at least three people
that we know of to unaliving themselves
i mean this is this is a pit of hell man
uh it really is kiwi docks chloe sagel
in 2013 they harassed her
and everyone connected to her for five
years
uh near the end she expressed unaliving
herself on facebook
then kiwi forms kiwi farms reported her
facebook page got her
suspended and weeks later she did
unalive or so wow
uh julie terry berry a canadian woman
died of unalive herself 2016 following
sustained harassment from kiwi farm
users
following terry farm's death joshua moon
he's the owner of the website posted a
note on forum claiming that kiwi farms
and its users had no responsibility
wait to see the owner is it near
no near is one of the victims
uh no the the nearest though right right
right no they both start with n their
their names so yes but here is the trans
person who
explicitly blamed them yes and they're
unalive no
near who's
a non-binary said that they had endured
lifelong bullying but the abuse had
recently come from kiwi farms had made
the harassment orders of magnitude worse
near stated that they and their friends
had been doxed and goaded into unaliving
themselves by members of the website and
that near had been mocked for being
autistic and they eventually did on
alive themselves and they left a note
which
i don't know if it's included here but i
remember
uh they they
they explicitly named kiwi farms and
said
i hope that someday this website gets
shut down
if you guys have an excerpt of that
that'd be interesting
uh about the new zealand so this guy the
owner of the uh website this goes on to
the christ church thing
he said to new zealand when they asked
him
to
take down the video
he said i don't give a single solitary
[ __ ] what section 50 of your
he's uses the effsler
laws say about sharing your email [ __ ]
you [ __ ] your [ __ ] whole country kiwi
farms has nothing to do with new zealand
whatever yada yada yeah
so this guy noel
this is him by the way
a [ __ ] uh handsome devil huh
this is the owner is this a recipe yeah
he's very no it's probably an old
picture i'm not sure
i wonder if like there's a
kiwi farms null page did they have a
page on him that'd be that'd be great
i don't know kind of interesting though
well he owned the website so he could
probably delete that this of course
as they say as always like to point out
the master race my friends
yep
this is what we're this is what we want
is this the only pictures of him yeah
this guy's a [ __ ] psycho piece of
[ __ ] uh
and uh yeah he's a bad dude
very bad dude
um
unlike 4chan where administrators have
little discretion over the harassment
campaigns moon's power over kiwi farm is
different moon himself was a frequent
poster and moderator
of kiwi farms under the username no
kiwi farms is extremely centralized with
josh moon right at the top deciding who
is targeted and who's not
he can delete any thread for any reason
so he's been basically
here's kefla's calling him out joshua
moon is currently lying about one of
this unalive victims on a site
faking their death and going into hiding
it's important for him to do this since
near suicide letter
explicitly blamed him
and his website
and directly in his death
um
yada yada yada whatever
the guy's a piece of [ __ ] so
we're so carefuls by the way
the the pit where the story goes is that
kefla's
uh
was victorious where no none other could
could they he she got it offline
she started a campaign
to totally shut down this website and it
seems like permanently
why were they targeting her so let's see
she was accused by kiwi farms being a
pedophile and groomer which is kind of
like what they say about all trans
people right right
they claim that she ran a discord server
that had minors doing uh sexual stuff
kefl's obviously denies that we'll ask
her about it
they've additionally have honed on to
the fact that couples has directed
people to homemade hormones
so
they started a campaign against her
saying that she's like a
a pedophile and stuff and
i think they were tr they were harassing
her to the level of
doxing her
people were showing up to her house i
mean what was the swatted
yeah why don't you bring her in i'll ask
her about it
swat swatted and then eventually she had
to move out of the country
and they still found her
it's insane you got to see this
i sent what you were looking for even
about near
where you said it's too late
here look at this she went to ireland
to escape their harassment
and these freaks
actually found out where she lives why
is this not loading
they found out where she lives and
continued their harassment
based on oh my god wait i thought it was
like a food picture no no it's that
picture at the top picture of the cat
yeah and you see the how you can see
just a little bit of the sheets that was
enough for them to figure out oh my god
uh what hotel it was as she was but
there was one she posted of like her
lunch too on her bed remember did you
see that one
that one was interesting
bro
uh why don't i bring her in and we can
ask her here's the note that near left
it's too late for me but i pray that
someone at some point will do something
about that website there's too many
people suffering and no one seems to
care because we are relatively nobody's
online and they know that evil triumphs
from good men do nothing
carefuls welcome hello how are you hey
it's nice to meet you all right nice to
meet you
so um
how's it going
um
i never thought that the first time that
i went to the united kingdom because i'm
in northern ireland right now would be
the week that the queen dies but
god it's been interesting
so are you there now or did you return
home
i'm still in northern ireland
yeah and art do people know where you're
living now or are you able to keep that
a secret
um no i i can't
but like i've been spotted multiple
times while i've been here already but
it was all swatting attempts they the
cops never pulled a gun on me on like
what happened uh in canada
um but it's happened so many times now
that the cops don't even take the call
seriously
who's scary are the iris are the irish
police cool about that stuff because
like in america you know they go crazy
like the first time we got swatted there
was like 20 police cars there's a
[ __ ] helicopter they cased the whole
house
with their guns drawn it was pretty nuts
like are the irish police cooler about
it
oh yeah no like um someone called in
saying that there was a stabbing in the
apartment i'm in and they just sent two
police officers and they're knocking at
the door like compared to what happened
in canada when i got like an assault
rifle pointed at me that's nothing cops
are playing with the cat here
that's interesting that the canadians
are also so militarized the police there
i didn't realize
oh my god this whole thing has been
insane like the last month and a half
so to walk me through it i want to take
it kind of from the top like how did you
initially get into this uh i don't even
call it a beef because it's like that
kind of downplays what it is but into
the spat with kiwi farms
so they started a thread on me on march
25th
and
you know how that goes they they started
off they doxed my mother they doxed me
uh they started doxxing other members of
my family they docs like eight of my
twitch mods
um
and you know but after that it was just
harassment for months up until august
5th
when someone impersonated me in an email
and sent it to every
uh local politician saying i have an
illegal firearm and i'm gonna go kill
every cisgender person i see at city
hall
so
yeah i wake up and the swat team arrests
me
um
they take me into custody and get a
search warrant they take all my
computers my phones
everything
um
so at that point it's like i stream for
a living and they just took my
way of earning a living away so i
decided that i would go to the media i
would talk about it
yeah
that's incredible how much damage they
did you know i've heard of swatting but
actually getting you arrested getting
the warrant and confiscated
that's pretty next level
it should surprise you that this website
is like leaked i mean
where's the legal and illegal
where's that line i mean where they're
actually doing illegal things
so how's the website allowed to stay up
are you familiar with the legality of
that
only
vaguely because
it's all american law and i'm
unfortunately canadian uh unfortunately
as far as i understand it's section 230
so
the owner of the website isn't
responsible for the actions of the users
yeah even if they're doing a legal stuff
or but it seems to be you know what it
is
to allow for those things to happen it's
weird well especially because the owner
seems to be
engaging in it or a lot specifically
allowing it so
golly there's got to be some legal i
hope there's some legal rep
repercussions for him
so what happened after you got basically
a warrant and all of your stuff
confiscated you went to the prison or
you got held in in some kind of journal
i just got held in a holding cell for
like 11 hours and then they released me
with no charges but uh they wouldn't
give me my stuff back and
the attorney that was representing me
said that the process of going through
digital friendships could take months oh
my gosh uh so i would i was really
freaked out um
i eventually got my stuff back in like
three days and got an apology from the
chief of police
so
yeah that was really nice um
not nice how they respond to the
situation but i'll i'll take it
when you decided to go and talk to the
media about it how do you get that done
like who would actually
listen it actually went pretty big um
like it started with like the local
press
and then it made its way to like um
provincial and then national press in
canada
um
but then it just kind of kept going
because like i knew by coming forward
with that that meant i had to confirm
where i lived
so i left i didn't want that to happen
again that was terrifying
so i went to a hotel and
yeah ethan already brought up what
happened at the hotel brought my cat
there
and they found out the bed sheets
they started ordering pizzas the hotel
and my dead name just to let let me know
they know where i am
god and that that that's got to make you
feel
unsafe right when they're like yeah yeah
like i mean like
you know i
i'm a pretty visible trans person online
i'm used to people saying mean things to
me all the time but when it escalates to
the point where they're trying to let me
know they know where i am and they're
willing to weaponize the police
that's
that's when it gets actually scary
yeah i mean well we kept getting swatted
at our house so we moved we were scared
as [ __ ] yeah i know i know that feeling
and i think it's obviously way more
intense for you
yeah so you went to prison
you came back you got your stuff back
so what kind of happened from there
you're back in your house
you got your computers do you go
streaming do you take do you try you go
to a hotel what happened
to aftermath
okay
so like after i got out i didn't get my
stuff back
um like i spent the next several days
thinking all right like how do i
tell the story
in order to get people to listen
and so i just like kind of spent days
thinking like how do i how do i do this
and
i
i got something together i got together
with like some of my friends and
we
we were able to start a campaign around
that
to pressure the police basically to give
me my stuff back because there were
i was still a suspect even though i was
the victim of a hate crime that
situation like someone's impersonating
me
um
and in the email there
they specifically made sure to include
my dead name so the police would also
start calling me by my dead name
like they wanted to humiliate me yeah
what are they doing so
just to go uh do an aside a little bit
so why is it that they targeted you and
hated you so much
you know it didn't really start until i
started covering politics on twitch like
i got really involved around the time
that
governor abbott and texas decide to have
the parents of transgender youth
investigated by child protective
services and i just started covering all
the other anti-trans bills and i was
getting into fights with like
conservative pundits
and it really pissed them off
they really didn't like that i have a
similar story i know about that the
minute i started talking about uh
politics
we started getting like insane amounts
of hate and scrutiny from from the
righties
um but but uh okay continue so
they didn't like you were talking about
politics so what happened kind of uh
how did you exp how did you feel that
they were
unhappy how did that first started
manifesting like a harassment
i think it's because like
right now it's like we're in a culture
war basically against trans people trans
people are at the epicenter of this
and there's a lot of people right now
convinced that
if you support trans youth you're a
pedophile
and so they started this entire smear
campaign to try and convince everyone
i'm a pedophile and everything i'm doing
is to support pedophilia
and any of the kids that i've supported
in their transition
are my grooming victims it's been really
[ __ ] up especially because i'm someone
who came out when i was a minor
i understand what it's like to be in
that position
yeah they had they've been accusing you
of
being a pedophile and a groomer actually
what's kind of crazy is i we've seen
people echoing that a lot even when we
said we'd have you on
some of our own fans were saying
don't have her on she's a groomer
so what would you say to them kind of
now that you have the opportunity to to
explain
explain that accusation that they level
against you
i think it's
i think the problem with it is is people
are using that word in two different
ways
like
people have
taken the word groomer which means
someone who is manipulating children
into doing sex acts and then they've
made that word mean someone who supports
trans people but if you don't know the
difference it means the same thing right
i mean i think most people think of
groomer as someone who's preparing a uh
i that
you yeah yeah i think that's that's the
common usage and i think that's what
they're saying about you
yeah it's just it's really frustrating
because well what what do they say what
are they basing it off of why are they
saying that
are they saying it
there literally is no basis for saying
it
so let's see they think because yeah
they claim that you had a discord server
with miners discussing uh
sexual stuff
i never had a discord server where i
discussed sexual stuff with minors
and then they also say
i guess one of their problems is that
you are supporting young people uh
young trans people
who didn't have access to hormones you
are direct telling them how to make
homemade hormones
oh my gosh
i know i i don't know how to make
hormone hormones i noticed the new thing
is they're saying that i'm teaching
people how to make hormones in their
bathtub which just sounds insane that
sounds difficult yeah i mean yeah how do
you do that i think you'd have to be
like a pretty talented chemist or
if that's even possible i don't know
so
yeah i mean that's the stuff that people
are saying but
what's the truth i mean you're you you
do have some kind of community where
you're helping young trans people right
that's like something that you're
passionate about
yeah
i mean um
yeah it's something that i've been
really passionate about because
all of these laws ended up coming out
and
it really hurts me on a personal level
like
i knew what it was like growing up like
in 2011 coming out at 16
and it seemed like the whole world's
against you
but
things are worse now than they were then
like back then no one knew what a trans
person was now it's like everyone does
and
in one way that visibility is great but
in the other way
it means more people who are bigoted
towards you
can express that
so you when did you transition at what
age
i was 16. and so
the people that you're kind of
advocating for or talking with these are
people who are like not finding support
within their families and their
communities and kind of
someone who doesn't have someone to lean
on to talk to to get additional
resources from is this the kind of thing
that you're doing with them
i mean some of them do actually have the
support of their families but some of
them don't like some of them are in like
really
fundamentalist christian households and
the only place they really feel safe
talking about being trans is on the
internet
and so where do you guys do this is it
like a discord or something or like a
community it's like a twitch stream
oh just on twitch
yeah
so it's all just out in the public
yeah because they're they they're they
make me it sound like you have some kind
of secret
or some community spot that's not
publicly seen where you're where you're
talking with kids and stuff but that's
not even the case
no
wow that's interesting
they really
they really
are just straight up lying huh
shouldn't surprise me that much but yeah
these people are the type of people who
harass people to the point where they
don't alive themselves
i try not to take what they say with the
grain of soul well
i don't know the expression you know
what i mean
so do you think uh do you think that was
their goal with you
probably honestly yeah yeah
because like i see them talk about other
trans people and they
the first thing is they don't want trans
people to even exist like you look
through the kind of stuff they say and
they're advocating for a higher
on a living rate for trans people like
unironically
which is already like super high right i
mean the the the percentage of trans
people that attempt to un-alive
themselves is like insanely high right
it's like one out of three
i actually don't know what the recent
statistic was
um
the one thing that i always thought was
kind of funny well not funny sad
actually
um there was that old statistic like 41
suicide attempt rates
and from what i remember it was actually
like a trans youth suicide attempt rate
but the more supports that they had like
supportive families or access to medical
care
that rate dropped significantly
yeah i think that's so that's so
important to understand about what trans
people go through i i saw that too um
that when they have supported their
family or friends or even i think the
study even said if they just have one
person in their life family friend
whoever that they can talk to about it
the rate of unaliving goes down
significantly i can't imagine even just
a twitch streamer to watch and talk
about it is probably really significant
right it says the data i have says 82 of
trans individuals have considered
unaliving themselves
that doesn't surprise me as of this year
40 have attempted to unalive i mean
that's just so [ __ ]
that's just so
horrible that that our society is so
[ __ ] up like that
well
so let's get back to the timeline um
oh of course
so you you went back to your
your house
you've got your stuff back you got the
apology uh from the police which is nice
so what happens uh from that point
that was the point where i decided that
i didn't feel safe in my house
so i decided to move to a hotel room yes
so you went to the hotel room you posted
a picture of your cat they somehow
figured that out i mean
these people
yeah they're [ __ ] up but they're also
they have this freakish talent they're
like insanely good at boxing people i
mean it's almost like
you you're giving them too much credit i
live in a small city and there's like
five hotels and only one of them had
like that specific spread of bed sheets
wasn't there another one though where
you posted like a picture of your lunch
and then they figured out oh okay so
what happened um
so like
after
what happened in that hotel room i was
like okay i'm gonna be sneaky they're
not gonna find me this time so i
i said i was gonna stay in some airbnbs
until i found a new apartment
and i decided instead to go to a
different hotel and start streaming with
the green screen
and what ended up happening
was i think it was after a week
my uber account got hacked
and my mom's uber account got hacked and
my brother's uber account got hacked and
we all got the same message
uh like this
um
like this automated voice telling us
that we got doxxed all of our
information was posted online because
someone has it out for us and that it's
not a threat but that we should be
careful
that came through the app
it came through it was like um
you know like one of those i don't know
the name for the type of voice
it's like the uh the ai voice yeah but
where did it come from where did the
what app did it come from on your phone
oh
oh no it was just a regular call because
they got our phone numbers when they
hacked our uber accounts oh they gave
you a call
yeah that's how they were able to get
our addresses because they had the
entire
uh order history on all of those
accounts wow damn that's so nuts man so
you go into one hotel
you they find out where you are
then what happens there you go to
another hotel
yeah i went to that hotel my uber gets
hacked
and at that point i'm just like okay
i'm
i just i was really upset because it's
like my family is collateral and
harassing me at this point
so i was like okay um i'm gonna stay
with my friend in northern ireland so i
get on a plane i go to northern ireland
and i do a stream there
and within a day they figure out where
we're staying here as well how did they
do that start showing up at the door
so our best guess
um because there was no way that they
could have figured out the unit number
they said it was because of the door
handles but it doesn't make sense
and we think that um
my hosts
one of her accounts got hacked
that had her address these people are so
nuts oh yeah
dedicated man
i can only imagine that will really
drive a person crazy like
the amount of
harassment
yeah
yeah it was like
yeah at that point i just i started um
i started the campaign because i wanted
to get cloudflare to drop kiwi farms
because i didn't know what i didn't know
what to do because if the site kept
going that was just gonna be my life
yeah um like you're you're a really big
content creator ethan you got like
millions of subscribers but your thread
was like 500 pages mine is like 2200
pages okay
2200 holy [ __ ] yeah no they
they [ __ ] hate me
wait can i swear on here yeah yeah it's
okay
yeah
so yeah you go to ireland northern
ireland
they dox you again is that when you
start this campaign you were like well
i'm just gonna go to war with this
website
yeah and so you like basically why did
you target first of all cloudflare
there were multiple companies that i
wanted to target um
cloudflare was the one that
i chose first because it was the biggest
one
and i knew that in the past cloudflare
had dropped other hate sites like the
daily stormer and h-chan so i thought
there would be a pretty good chance that
they would also drop kiwi farms
so when you started going starting that
campaign that must have really [ __ ]
if they hated you then you're
threatening their whole existence right
on the internet their whole
safe place to
try to make people unalign themselves so
it must have intensified did you
experience it like intense harassment
during that time or i mean was there
nothing more they could do
yeah i mean like someone even came
to the apartment in ireland
and they post they uh took a photo
outside the apartment with a note uh
calling me a transphobic slur telling
them telling me to get out of their
community
um and then they had a whole bunch of
kiwi farms nerd [ __ ] on the letter
that's like indecipherable to anyone who
goes outside
wow
so
i was following this
you're actually getting a lot of
momentum here to get this website
taken down by cloudflare and eventually
they put out the owner of cloudfair put
out a statement he said
we're not going to do anything
we had taken down the daily stormer
which is like a white supremacist
website in the past and he regretted it
really because he doesn't want to be the
arbiter of like what websites stay and
what websites go
but
it turned out only like a day or two
later
he did take it offline what happened in
between those two time periods
what he said um
because when it went offline there was a
big block screen that said
um this website presents an imminent an
emergency threat to human life and has
been blocked by cloudflare security
services and he put out a big statement
that was basically stating in the last
48 hours
the threats had intensified to the point
where multiple law enforcement services
had to get involved and they weren't
able to keep up with how many threats
were happening like they made two
different bomb threats against me
and i'm in northern ireland like
now
the history here not a good place to
make it
yeah yeah not the place
yeah i saw actually
it's pretty incredible they all it was
almost like they did
undid themselves uh to your to your end
because
i saw a lot of stuff on kiwi farms of
them just making straight up death
threats against you
like credible death threats with your
address and i think at that point the
owner was like okay now i have a reason
at least
to stop supporting them
and um kind of interesting that they
got themselves shut down in a way and
achieved your goal for for you
i think it was a few things
the site has kind of been in relative
obscurity for the majority of the time
that it's existed and they got pretty
emboldened over the years like they
didn't get shut down over what happened
with the christchurch massacre or the
multiple people on aliving themselves or
any of the crazy [ __ ] that they got
involved in
um
but not only that
even though
it took
a whole bunch of horrible stuff
happening to someone
who already had like
a pretty visible presence online
people have been trying to get this site
offline for like a decade
so there was so much backing
when i started this so true it's such a
win for the world i mean these people
are just
demons man they're just harassing
everybody to know and
i want to give you opportunity to talk
about this because there's people
who are pointing this out that on your
website kefls.gg you'll have a link here
that says do it d-i-y-h-r-t
yeah so so it's it's a website where
people can learn about diy hormones
basically
um
if you're in a situation you live in a
state where there's no health care
provider
and you're forced to do that yourself
like find it
like at a pharmacy in a different
country
it's a resource that's available so when
it says do it yourself what does that
mean though you're not there that almost
implies you're making the hormones no
you don't make the hormones okay so i
think it's just a misnomer there yeah
when it means when it's do it yourself
it's like
you have to get the prescription
yourself because there's no doctor
available
that makes sense so i think the reason
that it's offered because people
i feel like people really misunderstand
the point
um
it's a last resort sort of thing
you should absolutely see a doctor
if you can
but for a lot of people they can't see a
doctor
that makes sense
there you go yeah uh yeah okay so she so
guys
there is no homemade hormones happening
here
there it is yeah i've seen an
endocrinologist the last 11 years if you
have access absolutely do it it's the
better route
right but if you don't
doing something drastic like this is
going to
improve your mental health and possibly
save your life right
yeah of course and it's like
um if you're diabetic
and you know there's no uh price cap on
insulin in the united states
so it a lot of people really struggle to
afford it i feel like people wouldn't
really have that much outrage if
americans are crossing the border to get
canadian insulin because it's cheaper
yeah but if we can consider like
transgender healthcare as healthcare i
don't see what the big problem actually
is i don't have a problem with it but i
think it's i actually i think it's great
what you're doing is helping people in
need
and potentially saving lives i think
it's just the psychos that think that
like you're you decided to be trans just
because you uh want to be different or
something the theory i don't even
[ __ ] get oh
no being tran being trans has made my
life significantly harder
yeah i don't think that's like something
that people seek out to uh
to live out but so
um
so
we got them dropped from cloudflare
but that's
why what's significant about that can't
they just go
to another hosting
okay so they didn't get dropped from
their hosts
i think they changed house recently but
what happened they got dropped from
cloudflare
and
they got the site back up immediately
under a russian domain and with a
russian uh ddos protection service and
then they got dropped in less than 24
hours and the site was offline again wow
any idea why the russians dropped them
that's interesting that they even cared
oh they put out a statement they said
that kiwi farms broke their acceptable
use policy
wow i i think it's because um
maybe these companies aren't used to a
pressure campaign to drop a website like
this like i'm sure they're getting like
hundreds of emails to drop this website
right and they're just like well [ __ ] it
i don't care about them yeah like what
are we making from this that's worth
this right
wow that's super interesting but so
cloudflare as i know it's a ddos race so
there's probably people who are
continuously trying to take kiwi farms
offline by ddosing them which is when
you overwhelm a site with requests
making it basically inaccessible
and so cloudflare is a service that
prevents ddosing
so when you get dropped from that and
you get dropped from the russian
counterpart they basically are unable to
go back up online right and that's where
we are now yeah
they found another one but it's really
unreliable and basically since that the
site has just been intermittently online
apparently joshua moon was really
plugging his cryptocurrency accounts in
the telegram today he's banned for like
paypal and visa and mastercard so it's
all he has wait when did he get banned
from all that stuff was that a recent
development i think that was during the
christchurch stuff okay so this guy's
already
he's a well-known piece of [ __ ]
yeah when he when the site uh when they
got dropped from cloudflare and then
ddosguard he put out a statement saying
that
um he thinks that the future of the site
is going to be like what happened to
either the daily stormer or 8-chan
where
what happened with the daily stormers
they continuously get dropped and
they're held together with twine and
duct tape jumping host to host and
domain to domain to keep online
or 8chan where they had to go up the
clear net entirely but the problem with
doing that and going on the dark net is
you can't reliably protect yourself from
ddos attacks
and
i don't encourage illegal behavior but
joshua moon is a piece of [ __ ] and he's
made a lot of really bad enemies over
the years
right
yeah i don't i don't feel too bad for
him his website getting ddos there
not setting any tears about that
so what do you think you think the
website's off for good now i mean if the
website was kiwifarms.net right
qbfarms.net
and
right now it's off just completely
offline there's nothing there
you know i actually don't i don't know
what's gonna happen but i know that
it doesn't really look good for the
future there's no big companies that are
reliable they're willing to support them
yeah and
even though
i ended the
like the campaign i started
i ended after six days after ddosguard
dropped them
but that didn't stop the people trying
to pressure the other companies that
have picked up kiwi farms
so i'm seeing people going at it all day
that's good that's a good i think it's a
it's a valiant fight man those people
are
i mean how did it's kind of how does a
website even exist just like
dedicated to hating everyone and
everything to the nth level where it's
like we don't just hate this person we
actively trying to [ __ ] ruin their
life and people aren't alive themselves
already yeah and citing that website as
a cause like how is it still going
they love it man
i think it's just because they don't
have anything
good in their lives you know like
they want to knock other people down so
they feel better about themselves
yes like textbook bullying but
all the worst people in the world found
a home in a website like this
um are you feeling
has your life kind of become a little
bit more calm since this happened or not
really
like honestly like after they got
dropped from the second ddos protection
i i felt like a huge weight
dropped off my shoulders because it's at
this point they're basically just trying
to keep themselves online
and
joshua moon put out a statement saying
ignore the twitter people
stop trying to troll them your
statements are getting us dropped from
hosts that's awesome
yeah
they locked all of the threads for all
of the organizers of the drop kiwi farms
campaign because
we were posting the [ __ ] they were
saying about us on twitter and making
people more mad
yeah
so basically
has the harassment stopped are you still
i mean you've won are they
surely they're angry but
i wonder since they've lost a central
place to congregate if the harassment
has eased
honestly
i'm still getting harassed and
i want to keep i want to go back to what
my life was like before this when i just
reacted to politics on twitch
and i feel like that's probably never
gonna go away
but i can accept that
as long as they're not trying to figure
out where i live and post it online and
send swat teams to my house and harass
my family
yeah that's a tough one
well it was a good fight honestly
i mean no i mean even whatever you you
achieved what many thought was
impossible and i think you know i'm glad
that website's gone yeah you know [ __ ]
them bro that
you know a lot of people are glad that
that website's down so
it's wild
yeah i don't think that's i don't think
that's hyperbole yeah
thanks i i had a lot of people reach out
to me over this who were getting
targeted by this site just to thank me
for it
um and it just meant a lot because they
went after so many [ __ ] people over
the years
i think a lot of people probably are
even scared to speak publicly about it
because then you make yourself a target
you know what i mean
yeah
and that was actually a thing like
a lot of the journalists that i started
speaking to about it were told that they
shouldn't talk about it because it could
there could be a streisand effect and
then the site gets more popular and i'm
so glad they were wrong
right yeah absolutely
well what's your plan now what um are
you back to streaming from your new
wherever you are now right now
um
right now i'm just like trying to
settle down now that the dust is
settling and i want to get back to
streaming when i can
um
it's looking good i'm actually for the
first time in over a month optimistic
about things
that's great
well i'm happy to hear that
yeah i'm happy you have a place
you're feeling relatively safe hopefully
and i think you should get back to
streaming as soon as you can
and uh kefl's
on twitch is where people can find you
and you discuss politics and all kinds
of things
and uh
[ __ ] kiwi farms forever
[ __ ] those guys yeah
um
well thank you for your service
a soldier you're a
soldier the online culture war
you're in the front lines you're in the
trenches
taking grenades
oh you know what we could do you know
what we could do together uh since since
we're here should we have a pride minute
together just uh i don't know if you
know about our pride minutes kefir i
don't know about the pride what's the
pride minute
yeah so
jordan peterson
was like what's with pride month it's
too long
pride day more like months
yeah so so we said you know what jordan
a a day is too much let's shorten it a
pride minute
so we like to celebrate pride for one
minute and then and then quickly to
encourage people to get back in the
closet afterwards
so would you like to celebrate a pride
minute with us in your honor
okay absolutely
all right go ahead uh
during this prime minute we like to
encourage everybody to
be their true self
you know nobody should be able to judge
you for who you are right keffels i mean
is there anything you want to say to the
lgbtq class people out there during
pride minutes yeah absolutely
never let anyone push you around right
stand up against people who are bullying
you who don't want you to be proud of
who you are that's it right they're
we are so much stronger when we stick
together solidarity
yeah it was up for 10 years and we all
came together and kicked its ass in a
week
keep going
i'm
i'm hoping for a future where the trans
community and the gay community and all
of the different
marginalized communities can come
together and fight together and build a
better future for all of us
that is just right on uh
yeah yeah so
yeah i'm gonna have to stop you there
no more
all right i'm gonna have to stop you
there no more pride okay back in the
closet i am not gay
everyone please uh uh i invite you all
to feel ashamed and uh okay yourself now
because we're back
five minute is over
um we can't well actually we can't have
this conversation anymore carefuls
because prepping it's over and uh you
should feel deeply ashamed now so
i'm sorry i'm going back in the closet i
guess i need i need a guy's name can i
be ethan too sure
be whatever you want just don't be trans
anymore it's it's uh it's deeply
shameful
all right
so prime minister but thank you for
celebrating that pride minute with us
that was yeah that was a fun
it was a good moment we had
[Music]
and um oh we do like a christian minute
now after bribing it oh lord
lord may we smite down these trends
oh lord
they says that uh pakistan is flooded
that's the holy spirit
every time a man takes a replacement
hormone i'm not gay no more a child
drowns in pakistan
lord jesus i felt gay
yes sorry i want to i won't make i
projected to you it's okay yeah i didn't
i didn't know about this man not
primarily then
[Laughter]
every time a man kiss another man
a child dies in birth
amen
amen amen amen
come on now
[Music]
every time a woman goes down on another
woman
a queen dies amen
queen elizabeth rest in peace
um anyway couples thank you so much for
calling in uh it's been a pleasure oh
yeah this has been great i'm honestly
i'm
impressed and i'm proud of what you've
achieved it's it's really uh it's really
something this really is something i
mean it's it's heroic i gotta say it
it is well
let's just hope this is the start
yes sir yes ma'am and
um so twitch guys you can follow kefl's
on twitch
hopefully you'll be back online soon and
you guys can all enjoy her content there
uh but thank you so much for calling it
was so nice to talk to you and uh thanks
for spending your time with us here okay
problems
absolutely yeah thank you all of you all
right thank you take care now
bye bye back in the closet
no
five minute is over
[Applause]
a podcast host talks to a trans person
an angel loses its wings
unimportant announcements
this was your fault trans people
you killed the queen amen
y'all killed the queen with your
transgender [ __ ]
a bunch of dudes kissing dudes amen
the queen is now dead because y'all
[Music]
that hairy styles in his skirt amen
prince charles is dead
cause harry styles wore a skirt
an important announcement buckingham
palace has announced the death of her
majesty queen elizabeth lord help me
[Music]
oh lord
every time
a woman
taste vagina more lord
a thousand chinese people
die of heat stroke amen
oh we like that though we like when the
please get your donations in now lord
god run god don't run for free y'all
please go to christ loves christ
love.org
[Music]
christ
love.jesus get those donations in jesus
christ
this [ __ ] don't pay for itself now
all right
jesus is your source
amen
i tell you what man i've been down to
that pride parade
and i seen a gay man with a dildo
how dare you a big old deal to the size
of my arm god damn it
not only did it make me feel insecure
about my own manhood
it made me think about the great words
that jesus once said he said
lord
lest ye play with the giant phallus
lest ye
be drowned in the waters of hell you're
saying it's been longer than a minute
[Music]
decides how long a minute is
as you know moses lived to be 5 000
years old admit it is what i say it is
darling now things are impossible now i
know your place girls
gotta brush up brush up on the
the bible verses a little bit
i feel like there's a lot of
misinformation the bible says as you all
shut the [ __ ] up or face hellfire
that's sarah bathroom
[Music]
it's in ezekiel 25 7. dan is a hater ass
[ __ ] ezekiel 25 17 actually
hater ass [ __ ] that one's my favorite
oh there is the book of daniel however
the book of daniel 25 17. dan is a hater
he shall
silence himself god shall smite me down
with various angers
repent
king repent now boy from james bible
maybe head on over to godslove.gov and
get those donations here now
we got some silver solution be curing
covert and all kinds of things that's
the blood of god you take three of these
silver solutions you won't gay no more
but i'm gonna repent i'm gonna download
it olive tree
saved how do i know that olive tree boy
you guys i feel so moved right now i'm
thinking about putting in my instabio
dan is a hater psalms 101. it's a psalms
ye god shall meet a man one day named
dan
and you shall know him as the hater thy
god
then the hater shall bring a thousand
years of darkness onto this planet
you're getting tomatoes and you shout
you're getting tomatoes no i think
you're getting tomatoes
are you guys and damn the hater of
righteous god we love this son of god
you're okay anyone throwing tomatoes
shall be smitten
with god's furious hang
hey guys i'm so sorry to interrupt we
gotta go to break head on down over to
godsjustice.org and get yourself a
gay be gone potion stick your finger
yes sir
we selling our own hormones down here at
god be
so far 72 are saying you are being
tomatoed god damn it you all are going
to hell
[ __ ] god damn it god [ __ ] curse
[ __ ] damn god [ __ ]
god damn it
god [ __ ] my god damn it holy [ __ ]
well [ __ ] ballsave yeah
christ on a goat
holy [ __ ] not christ like to be cursing
like i know i'm trying to go i'm got a
jesus getting reamed by a goat dog no no
no jesus [ __ ] a goat damn it
yo really damn didn't it you gotta stop
y'all really damn did it this time boy
i'm gonna be mad for example damn god
damn it a dog humping jesus damn it
lord i'm taking the lord's name in vain
now because he's all tomato in me for
example
there's starving kids in africa that
would eat those tomatoes y'all damn
unchristian jesus take it in the
ass by a goat old habit god damn jesus
lord help man
chad said ethan is broken
[Music]
the israelites i'm just trying to make
sure we're good with god after that
kefla said yeah
i don't know if he appreciates you
talking about getting [ __ ] in the ass
by a goat i'm just saying there's a
hurricane one and only there was a there
was a tropical storm off the coast of
california right that almost hit us
causing catastrophic floods the only
reason it reared off and now we're just
going to get a little bit of
pleasant rain is because
i didn't never kissed a dude
i felt worthless that's right i've been
walking kiss your dude
i've been walking to kiss a dude lord
knows those [ __ ] be tempting me
no no no people say we've switched over
it's bathroom a minute and god said
take this here tropical stone
unemployment rate
off into the ocean
announcement buckingham palace has
announced the death of her majesty queen
elizabeth iii
[Music]
actually i'm gonna go to the bathroom
um
thank you to capohl's an inspiration
really
heroic what she's been through and what
she accomplished actually yeah
i was watching a lot of all that
developed on
twitter
and just thinking like
what incredible it is what she achieved
so when we come back
we're actually going to have a a moving
tribute
to our dearly departed queen
who we love so well
there she is
we're gonna save her as this song says
okay
what's god could not do
because she died obviously
i have a lot of questions but i'm gonna
go pee and i'll be right back okay thank
you have fun
somebody asked can we have a show with
super mega [ __ ] no did you see the
beginning of this episode
they're banned from the [ __ ] premises
permanently
i want to say something okay i'm related
now that no just you ila it might be a
good time to talk about
um so i had lena's sister and their
friend staying with us for a whole week
and so we did some traveling while we
were together and i gotta say
it is not easy being a girl
i i mean obviously i'll never understand
the full extent but what happened it's
just something we always say but i feel
like as men we forget just how hard it
is just everywhere they go they got
harassed everywhere
everywhere yeah it didn't matter
all three of them uh we went to las
vegas some guy looks selena and like a
group of other guys and goes damn look
at them titties oh my god uh not even a
half hour later we're in a casino some
guy grabs her sister by the hand
and uh yeah that's just vegas i mean it
happened everywhere we were everywhere
yeah
that's
um so messed up and like you would tell
any any woman or girl about it and they
would not be surprised no not even a
little bit yeah yeah yeah it was crazy
they were all telling me stories of
stuff that happened to them and like
they don't you know not that any girl
deserves it of course i'm saying they
don't even go out like that they don't
they don't party they don't do anything
they're usually just stay at home and
some of the stories they had were insane
i couldn't believe it matter of fact
yeah ab saw firsthand what we go through
what we have to deal with on a regular
basis yeah yeah yeah i mean growing up
as a kid i had to walk like 20 minutes
home from school
and i would get like always getting
people calling at me i was a kid wow
yeah
and um it's it's shaped up like how i
dress that's why i don't dress you know
like
showing too much and just everything
that i do
it's it's wild to think back about it
and to realize like
how
messed up all that stuff is yeah it's
insane and i've had many
inappropriate things happen to me
throughout my whole life from being a
kid to
all ages so
yeah
yep
it is crazy
me too ela
love you you too
yeah
um so every time i get to talk to ethan
about stuff like that i see his like you
know
realization of how different it is and
guys are just don't know yeah
it's man
like i said that trip alone every time
we left the house i think every time
when we were in san diego there was like
six dudes just staring at my
sister-in-law and she stands by my side
and says can you stand in front of me
these guys are staring at me i'm like
where and i turn and i look at her
and they did not break eye contact just
continue to lick look like six dudes not
breaking eye contact it was
yeah the older i get the more i've
noticed that i
structure my life around
making sure that i'm safe like first
right and i have i have to like alter
the things that i do to make sure
that is fine and then my happiness will
come second right
it's just it's
stuff that people don't think about
oh we just got a comment from the grid
big grid
hey it's great fun fact the pastor's
screaming how dare you and shame on you
is the sound bite is my uncle
i don't support anything he says
really no way that's why he's got a
crazy uncle grid was one of the
contestants in the diss track yeah i
remember
he posted he posted on the server about
how how many times i missp said his name
and i think you did it again just now
i sent i sent it the compilation big
grid bro
and also ab just before we move on like
lots of ice lina what you said about um
you were you felt afterwards maybe
guilty that you didn't with the stuff
with lena and the janitor that maybe you
didn't like act
enough and it's like that's also a
problem you know how men are
yeah
kind of like conditioned to think that
they need to be
men up and i don't know like what you
did was perfect you know you shouldn't
have done anything other than that
were you talking about how you did you
report him did you mention that uh yeah
i did um i'm still
dealing with it right now but i will
update everyone as it goes along yeah so
here
uh
big gritty
big grid boy
posted this apparently i've been saying
his name wrong
i think i've been saying it right and
you've been writing it wrong that was
awesome that was fun
gritty
my little gritty let's uh let's finish
it off legend of the grind seth one
legend a legend of the grid actually is
what he goes by okay maybe
uh legend of grid for ten dollars he
just realized that youtube brought you
back to the comments oh that's so funny
and every time you say it wrong big grid
but mine are better
a little gritty a little gritty a little
gritty or a big grid
yeah i'm just saying i'm working with
you i'm trying to
work with me
damn jimmy's been so wild on his
instagram ela have you been seeing that
i just see the kind of stuff you guys
let me show you some of the insanity
that's going on jimmy
he uh he wants to host the steamies now
that's his new campaign
jimmy i can't i wouldn't be able to get
through one award with him
i mean he's such a oh here he's got a
rip queen
rip queen of england you would have
loved the jersey outlaw they were they
were about the same age i mean
that's giving me bieber and frank vibes
it's funny because you remember that
scandal oh yeah yeah people have um
people on the who watch the show are
well aware of how i feel about jimmy lee
um but all of these jimmy posts on
instagram
all the usual suspects here
they keep telling me it's like jimmy is
they're ruining my instagram feed like
they need to stop it's like way too much
this is the funniest thing jimmy lee has
ever done he's not doing it he's just
posting it still though it is the
funniest thing jimmy lee has ever done
it is incredible that he's posting it
like this one i loved uh this is a
serious message jimmy and the meme team
are just having fun can't mute the
jersey outlaw because one of you guys
said you were going to mute him right
so this is the response of that oh yeah
i have a muted
yes he's so this is for you abs yeah we
love the h3 crew we support zach at his
live show support olivia's plays support
sam's art shop bye teddy fresh don't ask
ab about his camel be nice to dan and
nothing for ian
doesn't support my art shop either what
the [ __ ] jimmy
well there's one where where jimmy has
actually replaced me on the show did you
see that one
uh
he's taken my job and ian says it was
for the best so
um
let's see what else we got here
[Music]
i mean this is just such a [ __ ] show you
guys
ethan it's hell my friend and it's like
12 posts a day it's pretty incredible
though
i feel like this is what the gates of
hell is like this one was good
ryan cavanaugh loves says i love jimmy
ware
[Music]
yeah so
pretty interesting where's the one he
replaced you that's what i'm the
important update on the left
middle left
important update jimmy lee has taken
dan's spot on the podcast i love you dan
but it was for the best and then you're
just saying teddy fred
and whoever is making because i think
there's a number of people that are
making these memes and sending them
there's one person in particular who
likes just putting this same picture of
bobby lee in every single yeah yeah yeah
i don't know why he's there what the
relevance is it's a funny photo i love
it
i love the consistency yeah jimmy you're
out there man doing whatever it is
you're doing huh
so there's that and then
um
so let's move on to
basically let's get real serious here
now
uh this is a content warning for
everybody who's in serious morning
with peace and love if you are a fan of
royalty
if you are in serious mourning from the
queen's passing i want to tell you if
you believe that your blood makes you
less than other people
now is not the time to watch
dan is coming right out all right savage
not during my disclaimer dan
that is a disclaimer i'm telling you
with peace and love please
on september 9th after 9 3 20 pacific
time do not tune in thank you thank you
we will be pouring beans on the cadaver
of
of the queen be peace and love peace we
will be desecrating her corpse with the
serious message i thought we're honoring
we're honestly supposed to be i'm just
you're framing it you know i want i
don't want them to if they're you know
what i mean right okay i'm just telling
you what's happening
an important announcement buckingham
during my palace
all right it's party time
[Music]
i always thank glenn i don't know the
chat like i'm sorry i'm doing the show
here i always say thank you lena don't i
lena
yes always people think i'm being rude
to you i mean what the [ __ ] i can't
thank you yeah no every time he does i
say thank you lena here i'll just start
doing this thank you thank you thank you
thank you
but who i should really be thinking is
game stuff for this insane i'm so
energized
you are
let's go
this is the best thing man gamer sub
forever bro
yeah so uh okay i feel like you've all
properly been warned so i don't want to
hear any complaining okay that we are
disrespectful to the queen you got it
i don't know if that's gonna work
you've been warned
right
so with all that being said
the queen has passed away
at the young age of
96.
who could have seen this soon in fact
why do the good always die young
[Music]
she was taken too soon from us
she reigned over england for 70 years
yes yes
did god save her or not god save the
queen
was she saved or not she lived to 96.
but she still died
was she saved that was jake paul was the
queen saved or not we shall never know
96
that's the same thing
he was saved in the end
but one fair summer day god said no more
i shall not save you again
the final save i saved you one day too
many
someone saved me someone saved me
the royal family had this to say and the
shocking passing of the queen
the queen died peacefully at belmore
this afternoon you know that meant she
went in agony
i don't wish we don't know that but then
she died peacefully she was like
i don't want to die i'm scared i don't
know
it could have been i'm just going to
believe how do we know she died
peacefully they always say that it's the
royal family twitter but they always
worry about their [ __ ]
not the royal family
the king and queen consort shall remain
at belmoral
this evening and return to london
tomorrow there she is our sweet
sweet queen elizabeth ii
yes
too soon gone
too soon gone
for none of us saw this coming
our lovely queen oh do i dare click this
not on the show no not alive it's off
screen ian said okay oh god this is just
this is so disrespectful do you see this
it's kobe
who just i guess he just dunked on her
in heaven probably
is that what i think that's him kobe
would bawl the queen up be honest yeah
of course
she ankle broke her kobe get off the
screen again ian
let that sink in so stupid
oh i hate those that's the worst all
right one more off screen
this one this one i mean no comment on
this one
that's tentacion
no whenever anyone dies his like
diehards always post that photo split
screen of him and then the person that
died yeah
i always found that weird because they
always used to call dmx yeah i grew up
with that being my ex
well
it can coexist
a statement from his majesty the king
my dear beloved mother
her majesty the queen
we never saw this coming
[Music]
but god said he would save her
[Music]
and yet she has
died
go off kane
the good always die young
in a moment of great sadness for me and
all members of my family we mourn
proudly
the passing of a cherished sovereign
whose death none of us saw coming
good morning my queens of tick tock
truly sense shock waves
but now i shall be king
and let's forget that old hag
because it's my show now [ __ ]
signed the king
yeah that guy kind of got [ __ ] though
because he's like 78 now how old is that
idiot king charles
freaking dumbass how old is he
uh yeah he's in his 70s i believe 73.
bro that guy was waiting to be king for
so long he's like mom just you gotta
and beat things up frankly
have you seen
the pictures of like his fingers and
[ __ ]
he ain't gonna be raining as long as uh
lizzy let me let me see them thingies
yeah he he looks like he tried to break
a holocroc whoa
wait what is that an inbred finger
those are like it's like insane
high blood pressure
yeah that looks like
yeah too many points that looks like
maybe some condition right like a blood
sauce
your fingers look like sausages
let me get them on the stove here cook
those up with some what's that one dish
in bubbles and bubbles bubbles and
squeak bubbles and squeak a couple of
squeaky bubbles there might bunkers and
squeeze hey you got a couple of squeaky
bubbles there
is charles sausage fingers worry the
fans
i'm worried about them sausage fingers
too but this is what happens when you're
in bread your fingers look like this
it's not
explained as hell
yeah no i'm sure it's a condition or
high blood pressure or something like
that yeah that's what i'm saying though
this is what happens when you breed with
your family you get sausage fingers i'm
saying there's nothing royal about it
bro you know he through that ring is
never coming off that ring is squeezing
for dear life we got to resize that
thing king
what causes swollen hands swollen hands
and figures can be caused by variety
things
okay thanks for that wait no you don't
really know
is one of them inbreeding
i think it's because he shakes hands
with the devil
oy king
out those picky little
those piggy little fingers
or a diet with a lot of salt in it
causes you to retain people saying water
retention yeah
back in england we call it as a peaky
tweaky wiki habsburg fungus
the king's funga shout out orange pico
we call that the king's funga now hunger
yeah so
pinky winkies
she became queen in 1952
and her son pinky winkies king charles
known as charles iii
charles three sizes bigger on my ring
size please
here's let's see some reactions to our
dearly departed queen
who he loves so well
what is poundland
it's a chain in britain but the name
just made me laugh when it sounds like
uh skeet uh team skeet poundland yeah
he's going to pound he's taking it a
pound land
uh i think it's there uh i remember
somebody saying it's uh like a dollar
tree or dollar store or something
that's pretty cool that's clever
so it's not where you go pound like
somewhere you gonna pound off yeah i
think i've gotten some sausage at
poundland actually have you yeah
get your pinky wheeler fingers on sale
at poundland in honor of our dearly new
king
rested this was funny because all these
big corporate companies are now
doing their condolences like poundland
the company
poundland the company
is expressing its condolences rest in
peace your majesty
all of us here at poundland
are mourning your loss did the ah
podcast make a tweet we did actually
oh we'll get to that later
is that in the yeah
even this is my favorite faze clan
yes faze clan has expressed their
condolences to the queen on this day
we're phased down
no phase up phase down for the queen
stays down for the queen fave
blanks half masked
memphis
[Music]
um
oh crazy frog
this one's my favorite crazy frog shout
out to the crazy frog
paying the respects rip to the queen
theodore loves this picture yeah that's
the same yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the queen
rip to the queen from crazy frog we
appreciate your condolences crazy frog
god is with you now crazy frog in a
better place you know crazy frog has a
duet with acon
it was a good number doesn't surprise me
really crazy frog was is a big
he's a big star crazy frog has a penis
he canotically has a yes it's got a tiny
little dingler there i see it when
theodore watches it
[Music]
it's like super popular with kids this
video it has like billions of views
because kids love it yeah deirdre likes
watching dancing it's just that like
tiny tiny little wiener there i watched
that [ __ ] when i was a kid and i play
the video game and everything
i think they censor it in some music
videos but they brought it back recently
the version that has like seven billion
views has it oh wow
it's not super it's not like what you
think it's not really super vulgar it's
also not necessary though
no it's not necessary but it's a crazy
frog the man's crazy
funko toys
oh
our condolences rest in peace her
majesty queen elizabeth ii
thank you funko toys you got the picture
is important
oh yes queen
queen elizabeth would have loved their
your funko toys
that probably went up in value like
insane wait is that a real
oh for sure it has to i'll check right
now do they not need her permission to
do that no it was probably out before
she passed
no i mean but in life would they need
her permission oh um to make queen swag
i don't know it's on amazon though
rest in peace please probably
let's start off i'm being good because i
want to order yeah right tonight i'm on
stockx
rip from young money clan
yo this is my [ __ ] right now it's a
young money clan
money clan they're a
fortnight clan right with a bunch of
literal like 10 year olds yo this is
kind of like a fan cam this is kind of
dope you got to play them gotta play the
audio it's a video oh i think it's the
shut the [ __ ] up young money i've been
following these people for years she's
longer no [ __ ] has died she was 96 years
old and was a great woman dedicated her
life to serving our country it's a
moment of great sadness for many around
the world and obviously the royal
nine-year-old fortnight player giving
his
he's kind condolences
spitting fast
pretty impressive for our kid
love the fan cam though that's my
favorite part
you know
they're very known for hitting the
gritty for ukraine
you hit that grid bro king low grid
what's a grid
that's just a little bit of a fortnight
dance oh you hit the grid for ukraine
ringo starr
beloved ringo starr sent the queen off
with a peace and love
he's happy about it i like that
he dropped a happy face
happy with sunglasses
nothing takes ringo down it's peace and
love peace and love all the way so true
[Music]
rip
bozo why does he need to say ringo at
the end of the sentence love ringo god
bless because he's a boomer god bless
queen elizabeth peace and love to all
the family peace and love ringo he
signs his tweets
hamilton hamilton
everyone at hamilton is deeply saddened
by the passing of her majesty
and it's so ironic
do you know what
you guys know what the play is yeah it's
about wow
her distant relative or how distant was
king
george uh i don't actually know if king
george was house of windsor or not
uh
but yeah it's about [ __ ] the
the
monarchy yeah yeah and in general
england true
true truth i saw a tweet that said if
you're really that upset maybe you
should have won the battle at yorktown
wait who who should have won england
england oh yeah
they took a l
in yorktown boy
here's hitting the gritty for ukraine
wait this is how old they are
wait wait wait
this is how old they are this is young
money
there's very much drama surrounding this
because people don't know it's actually
the guy talking who's owning the thing
or if he's like just a voice actor
there's so much uh speculation but this
is original content
no probably not ukraine
vladimir putin you better be scared
young money clan and i
we are getting wins for ukraine in
fortnight
and getting many victory royales
i hope you were scared
i could probably beat you in a 1v1
ymc let's go ukraine
i don't even know if that's a real voice
that's what i was going to say it
sounded ai generated
me and ian has been on this [ __ ] for a
while he says these immaculate like hard
pronounced words so
i think ian also agrees with me but i'm
not sure but i don't think it's an ai ai
i think it's a oh you are yeah
interesting
as getting good man
yeah layman sure les miserables les
miserables
les miserables
les miserables
yeah everyone that lit what the [ __ ]
this is like a hundred year old play
what are they everyone at also about a
revolution like overthrowing a monarchy
yes
i mean there's no limit like uh
we at little caesar express our deepest
condolences
we here at costco
deeply uh regret the passing of our
queen everyone at liz
mesrilal bills miserable
is set we're sad basically
jeff bozo
coming out with his condolences i can
think of no one who better personifies
duty
my deepest condolences to all the brits
mourning her
passing today i would lie
my name for the next king the queen said
and you're laughing jeff
shame on you
yeah jeff thinks he's in the running for
next uh
king
and i hope you guys like amazon over
there in the uk because
hell yeah god giveth and taketh away i
shall be the next king oh domino's did
um
i said you weren't caesar's but domino's
actually sent their condolences everyone
had dominoes
i don't think you can say speak for all
the dominoes there's got to be at least
one pizza maker who's [ __ ] the queen
i'd speak up and you're fired they're
big companies so you're probably right
it's gotta
be at least a few you just can't say
that everyone at domino's joins the
nations in the world and mourning the
death of the queen
i'm just saying you can't speak for
everyone there
well that is the uk branch i am curious
if the u.s branch good question right
here i don't exactly i mean they should
i'm on there right now no i'm not saying
that but they do do a lot of memeing is
there anyone from literally caesar's
offering i looked at little caesars
first no it wasn't there
i wonder what pizza is thinking at this
time where's pizza hut papa john's how's
pizza hut doing is barbara john made up
basically oh okay papa john i mean guys
you've got come on we got to know where
you stand on this issue mcdonald's
their banner is their bowls poppables
burger king
real quiet about the passing of the
queen that's [ __ ] up it's super [ __ ]
up
oh oh there's a special uk one i mean
even chucky cheese put out a statement
they did
we regret the passing of our dear queen
of england you're right pizza hut uk
please enjoy david
well that's what i'm looking at right
now on my screen
dan i couldn't see literally on my
screen no it's not that's the dominos
this is pizza
yeah w dan
looks like they coordinated it like the
same everything what the [ __ ]
w dan
pizza solidarity what are they all
copying each other i know nando's is
popular in uk did they issue hernandez
shikinandos
is good i don't even know what nando's
is the chicken place mando's uk
here it is yeah nando's what you got to
say
real quick
yeah my chicken bro
even nando's they're they're posting
brittany broski means
chad is asking is david okay oh no
i don't know we have a morning
we haven't checked in the british kebab
award my friends
is that what i think it is just they
celebrating kabobs you got it the
british kebab awards is with great
sadness
[Music]
the queen loved her what is that
people saying uh domino's ireland i just
want to point out uh i saw that too that
was a troll they did not actually dunk
on the death of the queen
queen elizabeth who'll be looking like a
kebab
what she's all i mean damn she's
she's overdone
i'm just saying it's the kebab awards
what the [ __ ] else they gonna say
timothy burke
now and now let's level it up oh this is
a video yeah yeah this is awesome
below it
below it sorry here we go
uh volume in the top right
[Applause]
thank you
and now let's level it up it's showtime
in the rams
because
the death of the queen probably does
give a lot of experience that's a that's
a big death and like you know that's a
lot of experience to drop to level up oh
in that sense yeah oh yeah no that's a
fat and can you imagine the loot
yeah jesus that's like that's that's uh
that's mythic to your raid loot right
there back to the future what the [ __ ]
you guys have to say about this [ __ ] if
you if you if you feel so bad go back
and save her old ass
back to the future back to the future
the musical
i want to point out
guys great skutt
all of us here at back to the future the
musical
are deeply saddened
well
someone in shot just said something
interesting what is arab worlds take
airbrush
i'll i'll look into that one yeah i
heard chevron actually issued uh
it probably did
actually i heard um oh so here was our
tribute elo
this was our tribute to the queen
[Music]
you hear it in your head i told him not
to write it
but you can hear it in your head
queen elizabeth very soon you go too
[Music]
very soon you go to hell
we always joke about him saying joe
biden goes to hell so what's the
difference to the queen why we gotta
hold her in higher reverence there's no
man above all men are created equal
that's what we rock here in the united
states won't believe that's what we're
rocking with what i'm saying we don't
believe in this [ __ ] monarch [ __ ]
we fought a whole damn war against y'all
down with the aristocracy down
very soon you've got to
wake up wake up queen elizabeth wake up
what the [ __ ] is this remember queen
elizabeth bbc presents changes into
block clothes after queen's death
i would maybe just fast forward just in
case bbc claims us um to get to his take
on it
oh this is arab world news yeah yeah
yeah my man my boy yeah
[Music]
okay cool interesting welcome my channel
again we have a breaking news now about
queen elizabeth ii has dead at age
96
raised in peace
here is what happens next with her death
her eldest son charlotte the former
prince of wales will leave the country
in the morning sorry hold on i'm going
to stop you there but get a load of this
photo bro
it's cursed it's cursed
nobody getting that vibe okay i'll move
on but we can't play it
and
head of state 414 commonwealth's realm
the national ensemble
passports police uniforms and even money
will need to be updated
on the other side bbc presenters
change into black clothes as royal
family rushed to the queen
bbc prison terms have changed onto black
clothes
suspending all regular programming until
6 7
watch this video a while ago prince
william was rushing to
build more
castle a few moments before thank you
air world news always
good insight i have to say his english
is getting better
i could tell by the way he pronounces
his bees he's not saying black black
well also the subtitles is understanding
everything he's saying so
that's a w right
there good insight though really
powerful thank you our world news we
love you for that
um
now guys
this is going to get a little dark that
was the one of people celebrating
or are mourning her here's the ones that
are
celebrating
and i don't condone these these people
are disgusting gritty is the way
ireland right now
come on
have some respect
these are the ugandan
uh yeah
yeah we all know the funeral dancers
yeah
here is this what's going down in
ireland yes oh my
god uh top right to a mute
lizzy's
what the [ __ ] they have a whole song
about it
but they they all know a song called
lizzie's in the box i think it's
probably another modified the lyrics
yeah to uh yeah that's the moment they
straight up lizzy's in the box
savage moment compilation
[Applause]
yeah it's based on casey and the
sunshine bands give it up
here's a live look at ireland this is
the meme the guy says at my biggest
haters funeral to make sure he's really
dead
[Laughter]
over 800 years of oppression from the
british to the irish yeah you know what
they got a right to to be bitter
to be salty
princess diana waiting to bounce queen
elizabeth at the gate of heaven
true
princess diana and queen elizabeth
reuniting in the afterlife you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
yeah rumor has it those two do not get
along heinz ireland it's a it's a joke
oh
no actually
that's a shame because they're trying to
do a little trolling
has some [ __ ] to say
[Music]
dana open up these pearly gates right
now
she ain't seeing this i'll tell you that
wow did you see the one i sent you last
night was like cold blooded just cold it
might be in here there there's a what it
won't be just straight mean these ones
are funny at least whatever happened to
empire
she's still a human being in it
oh that's just mean come on now
irish twitter this is the same one we've
seen three times now
i guess it was just that good
oops pour one out for queen elizabeth
that's the truth that's not even an
insult that's just real [ __ ]
oh yeah
the beans on toast and that oh that's
ian
i don't want to draw attention to it but
that's ian that's our boy
you poured one out did that tweet go
viral for you ian ah a little bit how
many likes did they get
uh i'm not sure do you want to talk
about
how you really feel about it
about what you know well you got [ __ ]
over
oh
yeah there was a lesser bean tweet about
10 minutes after mine
hassan retweeted that one
like 25 000. i think even higher dude i
think i saw it get way up there so you
think they stole your idea and hassan
[ __ ] you i mean i'm pretty sure no one
else made a connection of beans
to this
event you know it's a very original joke
yeah dude [ __ ] he got the rex chapman
retweet too
oh
yeah
i don't know i'm new to this
no
i see the one that took the dub over him
yeah here let me go to hassan's twitter
feed and uh find it real quick okay if i
could defend hassan a little bit um i
didn't even know that ian had a twitter
until this situation yesterday
that is true
a piece of [ __ ] dude this one got 160
000 that's right and by the way i didn't
want to rub it in but by the way ian
your post is way better this is way
better i agree
this post this picture sucks yeah they
just use the stock i literally i went
photoshopped
i cooked it up in the lab
i think people like better yeah maybe
maybe because it's
to the point i think people like that
it's a stock photo because that's part
of the meme culture these days yeah
that being said i liked yours better
yeah
or maybe maybe the joke is a little
diluted here because
you're preparing a meal i think really
you're not supposed to eat it you're
supposed to pour one out like in the
garbage because when you pour one out
for the homies it goes on the ground see
i disagree because
it's not just beans on its own like
beans on its own is not british it's the
toast bean combo that makes it british
the joke doesn't fully land when it's
just a can of beans well clearly the
people disagree with you it landed
like a bottom line is you don't want to
[ __ ] with mcdonald's
you don't want to [ __ ] with mcdonald's
surfs so like all the people crying
about the queen dying serfs that believe
that that's the better meme yeah i like
your better uni yeah
that's a shame
uh we saw this one but rep to the goats
the queen after winning in the gulag
what
she's respawning in war zone and call of
duty
you parachute back in when you've uh
when you've respawned and call of duty
you know
jesus who would put that poor nana in a
plane like that
whose idea was probably probably
youtuber for sure
uh another one that's three
uh queen elizabeth
let's see oh these guys are doing
flossing in the oh my god news report
i wonder if those guys got in trouble
they're having a hoop
yes
work it
those guys huh
oh no hassan is here the group chat
going absolutely fairly over her
majesty's passing
hey what's up [ __ ] did you hear her
majesty has shuffled off this
sexy coil i'm not gonna rebuild thing
but you guys you guys know how these go
queen elizabeth really dropped before
gta 6. let that sink in
it's true she's she lasted this long and
ended up
[Music]
sad
queen elizabeth spotify oh
queen elizabeth is currently not
listening to anything
because she's dead
i think that's the implication there yep
you got to find the one i sent you it
was just straight [ __ ] cold-blooded
bro
i mean it shocked even me do you have
like a we sent so many back and forth
over the last two days what was the
you got a hint or like i said was it
someone scroll up dude it was like it's
a picture of a tweet i think i tagged
you okay i'll i'll do my best it's just
it's a picture of a tweet and it's just
so cold-blooded
okay all right maybe i can find it i'm
scrolling i'm scrolling
i'm looking yeah you guys will find
it'll show up
so um
her majesty the queen well lots of
opinions lots of people have a lot to
say what do you think of what are you
how are you feeling in the wake of this
tragedy
i have no idea i don't really know much
about
the whole thing um
i've seen a little bit of the crown show
yeah the whole thing kind of feels silly
like she doesn't really do anything from
what i could tell no she doesn't it's
very bizarre concept i really don't know
how i feel about it but like
it's it i feel like it's bigger than me
and like i have no personal relation to
this topic so i kind of just feel like
i'm staying out of this one it's kind of
interesting because because
traditionally the monarch of england
just represents like
insane colonial oh is this one yeah so
this one blew my tits off just straight
up i heard the chief monarch of a
thieving raping genocidal empire is
finally dying may her pain be
excruciating jesus i was like whoa
that one is gnarly even for me i was
like that's a bit much
let's tone it down a little bit you ju
yeah that tweet got uh
removed was it removed by twitter she
deleted
uh violated twitter rules dude that was
a lot
i mean that's a lot don't you think even
for someone that's like [ __ ] the empire
yeah uh jeff bezos uh quote tweeted and
was like this is absurd blah blah blah
what yeah she did yeah so he uh i
believe they
got amazing they got a lot of heat for
that one
yeah people are saying the same in the
chat jeff bezos quote retweeted that yo
i'd be [ __ ] [ __ ] in my pants if bezos
quote tweeted my ass with like yo take
this guy down
hell yeah the richest person in the
world was like yeah [ __ ] this person
yeah
valiantly played
but anyway
uh look back on queen elizabeth's life
as you know
[Music]
she lived a long and an uh
illustrious life
looking back at her
well
this is young queen elizabeth hailing
hitler
uh uh yeah and they're we actually put
this album together specifically as a uh
uh a savage moment compilation this is a
queen elizabeth savage moment yeah yeah
so here she is
saluting with her mother
as edward uh uh
uh salutes hitler so that's very cool
but she's just a child i mean we can't
blame her she's seven who won't throw up
a zig hell every now and then i mean
choose seven try i thought that this was
definitely a like when somebody said
this and i was like no [ __ ] shot is
that real but apparently it is real
there's another one that's going around
online where she's next to hitler that
one's fake
yeah no obviously that's fake you ever
throw up a zig how it feels good you
know
the royal family even responded to this
when it
like leaked oh this photo yeah they said
they were they were disappointed
that this image had leaked
well let's be honest we know the english
aren't nazis they fought him for christ
they were bitter enemies
but
we love it
love to see it here she is with the
beloved
entertainer jimmy savelle jim will fix
it
yes the two that is knighting ceremony
actually he was knighted by the queen
which is uh
savage she has a savage move you know
jimmy's one of the uh
one of the uh
great british heroes
[Laughter]
when the british built concentration
camps in kenya yeah
what what does this have to do with the
queen well she
had just been coordinated the monarch
when this uh all went down in kenya okay
i'm right we'll pin that on her why not
the queen's hidden away cuz this one's
real good this is savage as hell she had
two first cousins who were like
had brutal
inbred disabilities
and when they were born
they told everyone they died and then
they just like put them in seclusion in
like homes
where they lived out their whole life in
seclusion
until they died at 87.
and they weren't visited by the royal
family at all wow yeah yo the queen knew
she had two first cousins straight up in
like
one flew over the cuckoo's nest yeah
institutionalized
that's like uh kennedy vibes where they
lobotomized his sister
true
rosemary the american royalty if you
will
man those those um
those queens push on man 87 good for you
well she overcompensated by not visiting
your cousins by marrying her other
cousins so
right there you go yeah
we love that you can't say she doesn't
love her family
and of course
wow add that to the cam savage moment
compilation her beloved son the
accomplished prince
edward andrew andrew
uh andrew yes with the with the very
esteemed uh jizz lane g lane maxwell
and a then 17 year old
who he definitely did not participate in
sex trafficking with
the queen
behemoth uh passionately denies
they were clearly just
good buddies
here is good old jeffrey epstein and uh
g-lane
at
the queen's cabin
and that's just she likes to share which
we love so well
she lives for the people
that includes epsilon
an exemplar of service
in fact i'm pretty sure uh epstein
probably got a massage in that cabin or
more than one
in honor of her
majesty maybe even from the queen
herself an important announcement
buckingham palace has announced the
death of her majesty queen elizabeth
[Music]
me
[Music]
stop
um
so that's your savage moments
compilations god save her
i'm a [ __ ] savage you gotta do it
and so here is the segment that we have
uh pl uh planned in her honor
now
obviously here you guys join me over
here do i have a mic over there or live
yeah
all right so we got
sir ethan klein
putting on a mic
ethan klein in front of uh
sir ethan cline
can you hear me okay cool
now obviously
we were not able to be in england to
send off the queen her majesty
and so we did our absolute best here to
give her a proper send-off
we have here how tall she was probably a
short lady right so we made her a coffin
of course
[Music]
and as tradition holds
we're gonna bury the queen
in a coffin of all the things she loves
most so she could take it into the
afterlife
[Music]
so she doesn't forget her son who she
loves so well
she was 5'4
5'4 okay
the crown jewel obviously
[Music]
then dennis said diamond stolen from
india in south africa is that right
well it's the crowns now
white wig case you need to adjudicate
[Music]
a corgi
we would kill a real one and put it in
there with you but
[Music]
you're the queen that's up to you and
illegal here
soccer
out
because they love soccer the english uh
football footy
football as they call it excuse me
was the queen a fan of soccer
football yeah she played until she died
you know every every tuesday here you
are your majesty
ian what is your opinion on the queen
though because you are half english are
you are you mourning you never said
um
yeah i mean you guys have all been
proper chuffed
and uh slagging off
answer the question frankly i'm
gobsmacked
i'd say
are you in mourning
are you you're taking the piss still
what about your dad he's full-blooded is
he in mourning he's in the woods i don't
even know if he found out
he doesn't even know no well
queen
a a a a a thing of uh english black tea
yes
take it
and finally
finally your majesty
what can only be described
[Music]
as a godly ruler
[Music]
what can only be described as a royal
helping of baked beans
take this with your majesty never be
hungry again
never be hungry again my queen
never be hungry again
never be hungry
go to heaven
[Music]
yeah
there you go
and of course
beans are not
without
the toast
my queen go go to heaven
never be hungry again
here i'll make a bean a bean sandwich
for you majesty
take a bite
i don't really want to buy it
it's not working i saw you actually
almost
so
and hold it in with uh royal tradition
[Music]
[Applause]
what a shot
and holding with the royal tradition
we shall send you with a royal departing
may you live out your days in pure
ecstasy beans
and uh
diana keep save us one for diana
an important announcement buckingham
palace has announced the death of her
majesty queen elizabeth ii oh [ __ ]
[Music]
where she died
[Music]
[Music]
fell off
fortnite dancing on here
all that we say
what is this a like a fertilizer uh yeah
we want a wheelbarrow
did you buy this for this how much was
this
sam how much
[Music]
it was i believe 50 bucks a fertilizer
what are we gonna do with this thing
well we don't we're sending we're gonna
put beans with the queen obviously i've
assured you we've wasted money in a lot
of stupid things it was an investment av
yeah let me know i'm saying that has
some utility all right can we send this
who do we send this to
buckingham palace what's the address one
one buckingham palace one one
look it up i won't give me the address
box you need tape
i'm a doc's the queen hold up
yeah what's the address there at
buckingham palace
london s w one a one a a uk uk
what but do you write buckingham palace
no you say for lizzy
for lizzie and the dresses
lina can you help me just take care of
this okay i need you to ship this uh
overnight apparently now i'll help you
yeah
just i guess male 1 well the queen's
dead so won't reach her so mail it to
king charles i guess yeah make sure it
says fragile like handle with care
i'm writing all of this down beautiful
thank you yeah and dude like the air
overnight
option
rail royal mail actually
all right lizzy
i have a good one
tata
[Music]
that's
that's a losing in a box right there
yeah just be careful guys okay
thank you
come on nothing not funny
all right
god save her huh
save that beautiful
kingdom smell is pretty awful
[Music]
i don't know why it's so strong
[Music]
wow
what a send-off
that was very emotional
yeah
what a send-off
uh with utmost respect
we
wish her
a safe passage into the
afterlife
lizzy in a box
that needs to be the name of like an
irish treat now
like a popsicle with like a cream in the
middle you know like jack in the box
lizzy in the box he's in the box it's
just a it's just like coffin that she
pops out of let's take it on it's a food
chain come on let's go take it to shark
tank
lizzy in the box is a name for like a
nice popsicle with some cream filling
i'm ready
put me in front of mr wonderful boy
lizzy i feel like
a hot dog food chain
a lizzy in the box because it's also
glizzy oh yeah eliza glizzy oh that's
good a lizzy in the box bite
oil take one lizzy
in the box or out of the box in the box
you daft
c word
box
box
zach you truly are a mad scientist back
there
thank you just box
[Laughter]
yes so there you go um
you know
and and again to the people that sent us
emails asking us to be respectful
of course we were going to be respectful
what do you think yeah
yeah and to to the people in the chat
right now saying that was um what did i
just saw one
that was disgustingly bad taste
i also don't like beans on toast so i
agree yeah
english food is awful i understand your
complaint yeah no i i it was up to me i
would have put a different food in there
disgusting but she likes she's like
[Music]
in the box might yo i did warn all you
guys if anyone's offended i did warn you
i gave a trigger warning
fans emails saying be respectful maybe
listen rather than do it anyway and say
just don't watch oh is that an update uh
that's just uh the person who wrote us
no it's an it's another person in the
chat
there's some oh what'd they say
they said you should have listened to
the fan to saying being respectful if
fans email saying be respectful maybe
listen well just rather than do it
anyway you're sensitive just don't watch
it what does it matter if i'm respectful
or not you know i mean she's already
dead
i put it another way you're a bunch of
[ __ ]
i guess i
it's messed up to to punch down to be
fair
and she is burning in hell so
i love you
dan do you think she's actually evil
though dan like what's your take on the
queen i mean probably not as an
individual but the institution is
disgusting i mean she was born into
unimaginable privilege she walks around
covered in stolen blood diamonds from
all of the former colonies of the uk
um
i mean i said the other day when we
heard the news
i do respect
queen elizabeth in one sense in that she
over
oversaw the complete decline of the
british empire into a rump state that
basically is totally irrelevant it's
basically the 51st state of the united
states at this point their former colony
we now own them
um and for that reason i mean she's kind
of based this is destroyed she kind of
destroyed the british empire so you know
and thoughts that's a lot
dan
i mean i'm praising her
no dan's a true patriot everyone knows
yeah exactly dan loves america so much
number one baby
you know like growing up sort of british
adjacent with my grandparents and my my
my mom even had some of the uh
there'd always be like porcelain
royalty [ __ ] around plates and things it
was it was always princess diana
she never had the porcelain clout at
least in my house my grandma's house so
funny no porcelain clout
yeah my mom i was just talking to my mom
on the phone uh last night and she was
like yeah queen elizabeth died
but princess diana what they did to her
i just can't believe it and like that
she just started talking about diana
that's interesting because the queen did
diana real dirty like
when she died the queen didn't even say
[ __ ] about it they didn't even lower the
flag while the whole country was in
mourning so a lot of people got got
really upset at the queen then because
she was being a bitter old hag about i
guess my mom is still upset princess
diana and you know um
i think reportedly the queen
and diana had a fraught relationship
because she wasn't like oh yes let's
have something like she was there like
hugging people with aids and [ __ ] which
was pretty crazy at the time
and so um yeah when she died the queen
was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] basically
basically right she didn't report it for
like five days yeah make a statement
about it at least i mean yeah yeah and
the whole country was they started
because everyone loved diana w diana y
w
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes so i mean
i mean if the uk was smart they would
take this opportunity yes she's an
institution over there and you know a
symbol of the country and everything but
it's time to let the monarchy go maybe
maybe she should be the last one maybe i
don't know what i think you know when
you asked me it's like i i don't really
know but just the idea of it it's like
can we just move on from that idea it's
a good way to end yeah everybody loved
her you know it was a you know go out on
a high note yeah but charles is like yo
what the [ __ ]
i'm 73 been waiting so long for this
[ __ ] shut up dan
get an absurd amount of taxpayer money
too just from being born
like over 100 million pounds or whatever
from the last year well that's i mean
yeah there's there's not like there's
better usage for that
you know
so anyway rest in peace
to her royal majesty
a respectful attribute
which one should we do next i guess we
should do the don't worry darling let's
do a pull you guys want don't worry
darling the movie drama with harry
styles
chris pine
and uh shia labeouf
or do you guys want the reddit post
about the dude who was having sex to
that crazy beat
you could play because we did
yeah
this one doesn't get claimed right
no claim let's talk about that
[Music]
harry
that's harry styles and chris pine i
feel bad skipping the movie one because
we worked so hard preparing that dude av
is gonna
oh well then he's gonna tear his hair
out if we don't do that let's do that no
i mean that is if can move
the people are gonna vote all right
it's just a lot of ends a lot
unimportant
buckingham palace has announced the
death of her majesty queen elizabeth ii
we got it
[Music]
well this one's kind of hard to dance
too
oh it's close get your votes in guys
very very close uh weird sex song is 53
it's very close oh it just flipped to
the other one harry and chris holy
smokes i guess people should know that
for the harry and chris story there is a
powerpoint that was made
yeah that might have faked the vote they
want both okay but like let's say
let's we may not have time for two we
might but the next one definitely is
getting covered
so get your votes in weird sex song
people
it's
we could close it out huh it's looking
like harry chris it their percentage
just keeps going up so all right let's
lock it up
all right sorry weird sex song but i'm
glad that there's interest in both
i have to warn you guys it's not an ian
level power point but yeah it's not yeah
we probably shouldn't build it up that
much it's more that it was just so
[ __ ] complicated that
seemed like the best way to kind of
okay so what this is an ab special
powerpoint right yeah maybe put this
together yeah okay maybe ian will rate
it at the end no i mean no he's a
different it's a different league
he's been going going in on this this
was this was a one-night powerpoint
you know
what ian does is like michelangelo yeah
he's the guy no offense to a b this is
just like a class project yeah yeah
i gotta say though i gotta say something
for a b real quick he worked on it and
then last night i was watching his
twitch stream and i saw there was a few
question marks in our group chat about
you know specific stuffs in the
powerpoint to really beef it up to
refine it and abe stepped away from his
twitch to get it done and get the job
done and save the show i had a lot of
questions for abe last night yeah and he
yeah and i was watching his twitch
stream lena took over and saved the day
there it is the man is dedicated dream
team right there a b is dedicated power
[Music]
or whatever the guy um
that was like mozart's rivals
yeah
but was like always kind of in his
shadow and everything
that's that's a b in this case
my grand power points are the are the uh
content quartz
that's true
those are your yeah that's your medium
yeah all right it's low it doesn't
compare to ian the thing is when ian
looks at a powerpoint he sees the figure
of the story and it's just a matter of
chipping it out right
now as a fan before i used to work here
i used to like but my favorite segments
watching ian's powerpoint uh
do it anymore huh
it's a lot ian has no time you can't
force an argument
[Music]
any possibility for a powerpoint coming
up here ian
the people have spoken i mean they want
it they need it
drumroll
i use google slides okay okay okay fair
enough we'll take the slide
just
i'm just clearing it for you know it's
time
never use powerpoint can we get a google
slides from union no
there you have it so don't blame me
people go yo
keep an eye down he's not letting him do
powerpoint i'm like man i'm [ __ ]
begging him i've got i'm doing other
stuff i guess no i know you're doing
other stuff i'm not accusing you there's
there's a new
baby is this a powerpoint or a google
slide
what do you want me to say it's a slide
so
there's a google slide king in town
right here i'm excited honestly
i use those slides too
so much easier you know what i think
someone needs to challenge ian like
actually
trying to do one up to his level and i
feel like that might tempt him to show
his master skills i appreciate that
thank you cam might be able to because
kim can you help us yeah maybe
you want to try to step to em i'm a
dummy i can't make anything interesting
i can i can make it visually pretty but
i'm a dum-dum i can't make the
information he's a big stupid idiot he's
a big [ __ ] idiot
stupid idiot you guys are forgetting my
powerpoint i made i gotta say i i take
back but i said zach is the king i the
powerpoint i made about the queen that
was powerful right yes thank you about
about the queen about her getting hit in
the face or it was a guard
tick tock or something like that but i
have no idea what you're talking about
you don't remember there was a tick tock
video where there was someone that was
supposed to be the queen in a royal
guard harassing her or something yeah
and uh we all said it was fake and zach
said no that's the real queen and we're
like okay come with your evidence
tomorrow and you put together a there it
is oh there it is yeah see there we go
pictures of the queen right
next to the band the queen by zach the
sound lad okay
so there she is rest in peace
and purse this is the point
it doesn't remember there was a talk and
there was a tick tock that everybody
thought it was her there was a guy up
guard who was filming yeah funny awkward
weird
side-by-side
case clothes it ain't the queen of
england so you closed your own case
there yep yeah i think so i will offer
my services to visually beef up any
power points in the office
to uh i think so maybe the whole crew
collaborate together
the whole crew but ian to collaborate
together to make one that could compete
with ian oh interesting the avengers of
powerpoint yeah i'll get together to
defeat his thanos
i would work on a powerpoint with you
kim like you know
thank you we could put something
together
we just have to find a topic we're
passionate about and then get to work on
it there's plenty of topics i'm
passionate about maybe about ian's lack
of a conspiracy powerpoint about ian's
lack of power points
i
i'm just i'm in mourning right now
yeah i understand
all right well speaking of powerpoints
let's not dilly dally like the queen
dying i mean she lived 96 let's not do
that let's not draw the thing out let's
just get to the point
so don't worry darling
is a movie that olivia wilde directed
the movie has gotten universal uh
uh they hated it the critics it's got
horrible it's got a one on imdb it's not
out to the public yet though
critics are hating it yeah but it
sparked a lot of buzz a lot of attention
even before the drama that made people
think it was possibly going to be good
this was olivia wilde's directorial
debut
but there was so much drama that came
out of it
that it's captivated everyone including
myself people have been talking about
this on social media so let's get
started um what is the t
just
are you sure that it was her directorial
neighborhood i thought it was that's
what i read no because didn't she direct
the
book smart i think yeah
yeah no she's directed other movies just
stick to the powerpoint
i'm sorry i'm
kidding
oh but yeah this is her second movie she
directed book smart a couple years ago
was the first one
all right well anyway
thank you dan
[Music]
don't worry darling so the many scandals
of don't worry darling so
the film features
a love triangle between harry styles
chris pine friend of the show
originally it had um
so by the way important note chris pine
is a friend of the show
we saw him at a restaurant a few weeks
ago and i took this photo okay
their forefront of the show yeah
he looked i saw him looking at me he
knew who i was but he was embarrassed to
say hi
he's probably watching right now
he just didn't want to disturb us no
there's been a theory
it's not true dan it's so stupid
[Music]
because were like why does ethan even
want to talk about this story doesn't
like seem like his normal world look at
the people voted it's an interesting
story i mean i agree it's an interesting
story it just didn't so then what's the
problem it's just theory
the theory is that ethan just wanted to
flex that he was
that he saw chris pine and that's what
he already did
yeah i showed it already i already
showed it but not on the show yes i did
oh did you i think i showed it
i don't thought he was i think he just
posted i don't think so i don't think
he's talking
i like the story you guys you think i
have to plan a whole segment around some
[Music]
that i saw chris pratt the reason
i believe i believe ethan because he's
big on tick tock and it's all over tick
tock it's like all that's on the table
why do you care so
thanks thanks a.b i don't i need your
[ __ ] belief why do you care
by the way 50 uh gifted uh subs just now
from powerpoint uh community contest is
that a proposal
hello so anyway the first
the first part
in the beginning
shia labeouf
le buff the booth
shy
shy by the way
who's a classic weirdo that guy gets a
weird [ __ ]
he's been accused of like spousal abuse
he recently had this crazy scandal he
wrote this whole movie about how his dad
is abusive and then he came out recently
he's like i lied about it all
the guy's a [ __ ] he's a little cuckoo
you know i have a i have a story he he
screamed at me once
oh yeah yeah yo you think you were put
in check you should see what you did to
shia labeouf
i was working a random event years ago
um
and
oh you know you know what it was
i was actually already working for you
guys and i got a call from my old work
and they were doing a show for shia
labeouf he was doing this bizarre
performance art thing in some loft
downtown and their show was crashing and
burning they were having all kinds of
tech issues and they needed help so i
went down there
and i was just had just gotten there was
getting the lay of the land to like kind
of figure out how to fix what was going
on and he like kicked in the [ __ ]
door and comes in because i guess they
were getting delayed they couldn't start
yet and he just starts screaming at
everybody what the [ __ ] is going on what
the [ __ ] and every like when are we
gonna get this ready and because i was
the guy there to fix it everybody in the
room just kind of like turns and looks
to me to answer so like i got there so
i'm all of a sudden like the target of
his wrath and he comes like stomping
over to me to scream in my face
i was like
as calmly as i could as
i just got here i'm the guy here to fix
your problem
so
if you want to just give me a few
minutes to figure out what's going on
but i don't know it just that was my one
run-in with shyla buff and it did not
leave a particularly good price he seems
to be a lot of friends
yeah a little nuts enemy in the show i
saw him at the gym once wearing skinny
jeans and tim's
lifting
okay
that's even bigger yes i swear
[Music]
he's credited with that whole style of
those like easy boots like the high nike
combat boots he was one of the first
ones to do it it's a vibe right now but
the gym is weird definitely he is kind
of a fashion icon
kanye room uh uh allegedly stole went
through
all this [ __ ] yeah
but anyway
so this is olivia wilde's movie
now she's apparently dating harry styles
so it is or it is yes it is it's her
movie okay
not her first movie that's she directed
book smart like two years ago
gotcha so how old is what's the age gap
there that seems a little weird she's
14 years older she's 38.
she's 38.
how old is harry harry is 28. oh that's
not that bad
that's not that bad
[Music]
okay 14.
it's the it's more the power dynamic
between she hired
him and she knew she was going to be
directing him and then she pursued a
relationship with him while they were
filming oh the actually that see i
forgot there's the other wrinkle
olivia was uh was married to
jason siddecko the guy who played ted
jason sudoku
what's his [ __ ] the legislation called
ted lasso ted lasso wait why
her
husband not following him
everybody stop talking let me just
explain
her husband olivia wilde's husband okay
it used to be ted lasso okay
and during the filming of this yeah
she left her husband for harry styles
well hairy style yeah and they have kids
and [ __ ]
she has kids with ted lasso yes she does
and they visited her on set they visited
her on set and she was having an affair
with harry styles yeah and left her
family now by the way i want to say in
the powerpoint though
that's what i'm this is a preview
should we not read the powerpoint i kind
of listen the powerpoint is just i never
i didn't ask for a powerpoint okay i
just want the file
okay
i just wanted
to we were saying that it was so hard to
understand i said would a powerpoint be
more visually pleasing you said you said
that'd be nice if you could pull
let me talk about it the way i want to
talk about it this is my [ __ ] project
remember you guys are all like oh it's a
conspiracy so he's gonna talk about this
[ __ ] picture okay so let me have my
moment and we already saw the pictures i
don't know why you're so passionate
about this unimportant
buckingham palace has announced the
death of her majesty queen elizabeth iii
so [ __ ] disrespectful to talk over
that announcement i apologize
shame on you dan and ap for talking over
that
an important announcement buckingham
palace has announced the death of her
majesty yeah elizabeth ii have some
respect you guys um people are saying
you may have had too much game or
something i know the gamers have got me
all [ __ ] jacked
let me talk about this though stop this
isn't about you baby isn't about your
[ __ ] powerpoint it's about mine i'm
not saying anything i'm not even about
that
dude what you go you go ethan asked me
to do a powerpoint because you're all
like [ __ ] this powerpoint
i i'm not saying [ __ ] the powerpoint
just let me do you talk about what i
want
to speak
let me speak
i'm really pumped to get back in the lab
exactly
you made a powerpoint let's let's follow
you know what i'm starting to feel like
this whole thing was just for me to be a
tool to bait ian into making a new
powerpoint
whoa whoa well first of all ian i've
never given you [ __ ]
or tried to control the pace of your
powerpoints this powerpoint was put
together
as an informational for me to present
this segment this is about me
yes okay this is why i'm watching now
ian if you present a powerpoint i'm not
saying [ __ ] i'm i'm presenting it as
intended in fact you've been presenting
your own powerpoints i didn't even touch
the reins okay but this is my [ __ ]
powerpoint let's get that straight i
commissioned this
and i didn't even want it
clearly go off queen
oh
that's too soon
now can i get some [ __ ] diesel quiet
gamers sucks
to do this
so
it's unattractive oh my god
olivia wilde
had an affair with harry styles
she was married to ted lasso and have
kids with them
and she [ __ ] ruined her home
to be with harry styles by the way i
know harry styles has a lot of stands
not the highest class
thing of him to do in my opinion
i will say
i agree with you
kind of shady for him yeah and that's
what caused a lot of contention on set
with florence and olivia
so how did that cause lawrence knows
jason sedakis oh
or at least this is all speculation of
whispers but it's pretty clear by their
actions on that you'll see later in the
powerpoint that i think everybody's
feeling the way we all think they do
okay that's interesting
yes so i don't know because like harry
styles they i think people hold him in
too high reverence this is kind of
[ __ ] up but there you have it
why was shot now why was shia labeouf
replaced
uh wild had previously said on variety
that his acting process she described as
not conductive to her production ethos
she accused the buff of possessing a
combative energy that left actress
florence pugh
who stars and don't worry darling
feeling uncomfortable
that's a lot that's a big accusation
she's basically saying this guy's a
toxic force
on set okay and we had to fire him
because he's making people uncomfortable
then this is where it goes upside down
shyla buff
says this is [ __ ]
i quit because i didn't we didn't have
enough time to rehearse in fact
he went further and he's like yo here's
a video
that olivia sent me
begging me to come back
this is referred doesn't this have a
name it's called the um
[Music]
the uh
the pew video what do they call it
there's like a whole
miss flow the miss flow videos
give me some volume
i just went
riding
my horse very sweaty but i wanted to
reach out because
i feel like i'm not ready to give up on
this yet and
i too am heartbroken and i want to
figure this out and
you know i think this might be a bit of
a wake-up call for miss flo
and i want to know if you're open to
giving this a shot with me
with us if she really commits if she
really puts her her mind and heart into
it at this point
and if you guys can make peace and i
respect your point of view i respect
hers but if you guys can do it what do
you think
is there hope is there hope will you let
me know okay
yeah so she's sending this video to shy
do people communicate like that in
videos
apparently
some people do
but what do you think she kind of said
that shy was like this piece of [ __ ]
and he's like yo here's a video for
begging me to come back kind of juicy
tea right
without knowing more i
could easily go her side or his side
depending
what the timeline was like she could
have said that before okay
interesting
and then i don't think it's proof for
anything so far from what i know so far
well the timeline is that
she was saying come back so he had
already left right she says i'm not
ready to give it up please come back she
yesterday
made a statement about miss flo that
call and she said that after
that phone call took place they gave it
another shot and then she didn't like
the way shia was acting yeah i mean okay
all right so it could easily be like
something of a timeline
situation where
something's still a little it's a little
embarrassing still for her oh totally
agree
i feel like she was so condescending
about florence
and this is a wake-up call for miss flo
but miss flo is an incredible and
professional actress right so she was
framing it like she was the problem yeah
possibly just playing both sides but
it's like a private
conversation i know i mean like
maybe she was a little upset she was
like miss flow but you know well anyway
i don't know i i don't know anything
about anybody here i'm just these are my
opinions from what i'm seeing so far
well florence who starred in this
now is complaining that the movie is not
good it's just she's like it's all about
sex scenes it doesn't make any sense
this movie sucks
she did not she says olivia wilde did an
interview last year after the trailer
came out and she claimed that she wanted
to make a film because there weren't any
good sex scenes
oh she said uh here's what she said
anymore pew did an interview
she said when it's reduced to your sex
scene or to watch the most famous man in
the world go down on someone it's not
why we do it it's not why i'm in this
industry obviously the nature of hiring
the most famous pop star in the world
you're going to have conversations like
that it's just not what i'm going to be
discussing because this movie is bigger
and better than that and people who mate
who made it are bigger and better than
that okay not exactly the way i
interpreted it
now here's where it gets really good
chris pines is in this movie
harry styles in this movie here's olivia
so here is them getting a standing
ovation
at some film festival
but watch this now you tell me what you
think of this
watch chris pine
[Music]
what is happening there
watch chris pineala if you would please
what is happening there
how would you just how would you
interpret that
body language
[Music]
i don't know if this is something that
happened by mistake or
for sure
how would you interpret his body
language no i see like he looks
disgusting yeah
i mean he looks like i can't [ __ ]
believe this guy okay yeah but and and
it's such a it's such a strong
[Music]
undeniable
reaction now he says
he found his glasses there
and he was relieved because he thought
he lost him or something like that
chris fine yeah but like he's on the
camera he's in the like that that that
reaction is so strong
oh well yeah he did grab the glasses but
how relieved can you be my god
no but he just put them down so actually
that doesn't make sense
i don't know people are saying he's
perry spit on him
if you watch it but watch harry i
thought that's what you're asking me
yeah it looks like he spit on it but it
looks like it could also not be what i
don't think harry spit on him that'd be
insane right
but i do wonder that the whole thing is
pretty weird dude you know
the spit
right
stay same chris pine misplaces
sunglasses
yeah likely story here you can see it in
slow motion
and then here it is uh
from another angle
okay
let's take a look
why are they sitting next to each other
because they start in the movie together
right it's all the cast there you could
tell there there were
no moments where harry and olivia were
standing next to each other like on the
red carpet they would not stand next to
each other and there's a video of her
like kind of telling him to come over
and he's just like not even looking at
her but they're dating right yeah i
think it's because they don't want any
they don't know they don't want any fuel
for people to talk about them yeah but
then he shouldn't have spit on chris
pine yeah he should have thought about
that i think
so
a twitter immediately starts posting
memes about this you can imagine it's a
[ __ ] storm
he threw a dead goat on him i mean
disrespectful
[Applause]
according chris pines pr team they give
this [ __ ] story friend of the show
by the way he says it's ridiculous
fabrication chris they're best friends
sure harry styles joked on stage about
the incident recently
formatting on this video doesn't work
okay
oh and then here
we get deeper into the drama ela
harry styles the amateur actor chris
pines has no respect for him
it's made obvious by this watch this you
know my favorite thing about the movie
is like it feels like a like a movie
it feels like a real like
you know
go to the the
film movie that
you know
the reason why you go
to watch something on the big screen i
think chris pine is disassociating with
disgust that hair he is this is a true
thespian this is captain kirk i mean
they could be friends still and he's
just like
got the look on his face like you just
said something really stupid well get up
no he [ __ ] can't stand them and
that's why harry spit on him don't you
understand
listen you know my favorite thing about
the movie he says that my favorite thing
about this movie is that it feels like a
movie
like it feels like a like a movie and
then he says that it feels like a real
like 30 more seconds it feels like a
movie it feels like a movie it feels
like you know
go to the
film movie twilight movies you know you
kind of the reason why you go
to watch something on the big screen i
think there it is
uh you know my face fascinating right
so also there was another thing
kind of a satellite issue there at a
presser
trying to promote the movie and
chris pine you know my
looking like a
people a lot of people said he looks
like a lesbian
those aren't my words
chris pine looking like a retired female
tennis player who announced match
doesn't think serena williams plays the
right way
chris pine rethinking his entire life
decision that led him to this
chris pine looking like he lost the
wyoming primary
chris pine looking like he's about to
unwillingly train some tributes
for the 74th hunger games okay
thoughts no
daddy yadda yadda all right lots of
enthusiasm
that's the t says thank you
okay
all right
bet you have nothing
what a powerpoint man talk about the
allegations i'm just saying this do you
see what i mean it's just information i
kind of see why dan was curious why you
wanted to talk about the story
there's not much there it wasn't my
theory just to be clear i just didn't
want to out anybody but like i said it
was whose theory was
i'm not doing that who's going to snitch
he's going to stitch
i'm not snitching blue snitching
i will say it was not me
okay an important announcement
buckingham palace has announced the
death of her majesty queen elizabeth ii
i thought it was funny everyone was
talking about it man you know
[Music]
i thought there was something more to it
based on how much people were talking
about it
olivia reacted to shy being sued for
abuse
also for not disclosing herpes and said
he was in a new interview he gets cold
sores
i'm a herpes advocate let me get at this
and educate on herpes what the [ __ ]
i mean shout out suzbab but i don't know
i understand what you just said
shout out herpes i guess i sent the
video that wasn't working in discord it
was just harry styles on stage in new
york like meme on the event
right yeah he's just saying oh i just
got done spitting on chris
all right so there you go i guess it was
not a great segment after all was it
i had fun but you know
[Laughter]
you have to witness it on tick tock you
don't actually think uh he spit on him
right no yeah i mean it's but
i don't know if i'm convinced that it
was just the sunglass vine because that
look was so could be you know how many
times i like i'll be holding my phone
and then i'm like where is my phone and
then you have that realization like oh
it's here right
but he's like
center stage during a standing ovation
you know i feel like he would have more
presence of mind
to not
i don't know man it's [ __ ]
interesting but okay
um a lot of people are saying they loved
it so okay good thank you
again
you know me i love this stuff
there it is
all right
up next and finally
we have the reddit post
that has gone so [ __ ] viral
it's incredible
this guy writes this whole story
i'll just read it to you guys
it's so [ __ ] funny
a little while back i was having sex
let me zoom in so small
researched ways to be better because i
was a little stiff and pretty i pretty
much had no idea what i was doing i read
online that you can play music and match
the rhythm in order to put on a better
form is that a real thing that sounds
kind of silly
to like hump on beat
it's kind of i feel like that'd be
awkward for the girl mm-hmm
it's like playing d it's like playing a
guitar hero right during sex
i searched lovemaking songs and slowly
created a playlist which i was
comfortable with the rhythm
there are a few songs in my playlist
however there's one song in particular
which actually happens to be my favorite
that my girlfriend hates and says it's
turned her off in a major way
i don't understand why is it taking her
two years to tell me she hates that song
it's a good love making song with good
rhythm
i feel the way i [ __ ] up is i could
have possibly asked her previously if
she likes the playlist or any of the
songs
that are changed but to leave it for two
years thinking our sex life was great
but in her eyes
has just ruined uh was ruined by music
has left the whole situation feeling
awkward and i'm a bit annoyed
i pretty much played this tune every
single time
so the amount of time she must have been
not enjoying it
when i thought the complete opposite is
annoying was also embarrassing
not to mention my previous partners
however they never complain about the
song so maybe it's just her
it's [ __ ] up the relationship because
sex feels awkward now the other day
we're having sex no music and i was
still thrusting to the tune of the song
in my head
she recognized this and asked me to stop
i thought this song was perfect and i
always thrust along with the tune and i
feel gives the perfect rhythm for doing
the deed i usually bust to the song and
find it devastating that she hates the
song oh my god okay so the punchline
obviously is the song so zach play r
this is the song
[Music]
the weirdest [ __ ] craziest song this
is the worst sex song i've ever heard in
my life
oh [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] funny
am i wrong ladies is this the worst
yeah multiple questions uh why did they
think that was a good song i don't know
but also like who would think that
there's one song to play every time you
have sex
like what the hell by itself is very
weird the whole pumping to the rhythm
ddr
you know
but also i have been wondering ever
since i read this could it be fake
because the story is like too funny
it always could be but yeah
it feels real
i suspect it's a troll but it's a
fantastic
yeah like yeah it's so [ __ ] funny
yeah well there's a lot of there was a
lot of fallout with people on tick tock
who some thought it was
confirmed to be them and then some
accounts deleted
people trying to confirm
his identity
uh but i was wondering
here's a tick tock that apparently
is him because
he linked to this reddit or this tick
tock at one point all right let me let
me just
it was very confusing because
there were lots of people claiming to be
him that were trolling so there were
trolls on top of trolls going on i after
a lot of decoding i'm pretty sure that
this is
the guy that posted it um
we do a little trolling it's called we
do there was another guy that a lot of
people thought was the guy it was the
one that you were telling me about ethan
that like pimply face guy yeah but after
digging a lot i'm pretty certain that
that one was so why do you think this is
the real one because at one point
the guy who posted this on reddit had
this tick tock account in his
description well the other one
well the other one what was confusing is
what what's the name of the account it's
like uh
put it up on screen real quick again
uh disciple of the cult so there was
another account disciple of the occult
that was the one that you saw ethan with
the pimply face guy jesus yeah so
i i i don't feel 100
uh well here it is confident on it but
i'm i'm pretty certain that this is the
real guy so here it is should i drop the
thrust pattern
because some people are curious i was
curious too i was like how the [ __ ] do
you hump to that
oh god
and what's funny is like if the music
song is not playing you could definitely
tell he was thrusting
to the song so i wanted to try it like
play the song for me i just want to feel
how the rhythm of that nila tell me
this sounds appealing to you
all right let me try it there's no way
that it does something like that it's
not even a question
[Music]
[Music]
you're way too fast for this how else
does he do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're getting there there you go yeah
anyone else want to give it a shot
ela
absolutely not are you hilah give it a
shot
not happening nobody else wants
to give it a shot i don't know if i can
embarrass myself like that
[Music]
come on everybody kicks out yeah here we
go
zack's up um
i just saw a comment say
this is traumatizing
what's actually funny is
anthony fantano back in uh 2011
gave this album
or was it a single no
i think it's an album yeah he gave it a
trying to draw the best damn picture he
can with the original eight i'm feeling
a strong seven on this
[Laughter]
he probably saw this and thought you
know if seven fentanyl
i remember when we were doing the story
like i'm like i've heard this before but
where did i hear this
and there's a show i used to watch
called workaholics
on comedy central sure i remember and it
it was in it and like i i think someone
oh that song was in it yeah someone put
the clip on the sub
and i'm like oh [ __ ] like that's where
it's from
wow that's interesting i watched that
show too but now that you say that i
remember it's like durs was getting out
of a trunk like there was a night of
partying or something like that like
yeah well there you go
we didn't get to
dirty dom made a video about me did you
know that it's pretty funny but
we're
well out of time here today so yeah oh
one last thing
this was a bizarre
twist on all of this um i'm trying to
find it real quick
the independent
which is a fairly prominent uh
publication
um hassan recreated the humping to that
dance or whatever and they wrote an
article about it why yeah
let me see
i found a repost of it on google news
i'm trying to
find the original source here uh
here let me just uh google the
title of it
some pucker attempts to nail reddit sex
song motion
he was nailing something
hassan is like
why is this on the independent
yeah
hassan [ __ ] thinks he's nailed the
thrusting lotion that's gone viral
could he be a world first
oh so is everyone trying to do this yeah
i've seen a few people yeah
it's not easy though it's not easy
for sure
there it is uh exclusive reporting
the fact that they wrote an article all
right guys well listen that's the show
happy friday
we've had a long show big show um
anything to announce next week
uh let me
what was that
oh you were about to do an announcement
you said announcement oh i see
um
no uh there
are a lot of guests getting put on the
books uh in the near future here but um
nothing next week the week after that
um the long-awaited young gravy episode
is happening
uh we had originally announced that a
couple two weeks
or next week
uh not next week but the week after yeah
are we gonna get gravy in the comment on
this whole addison raid thing that's
blowing my mind oh my god is he willing
to talk about it
yeah yeah he doesn't have a problem
talking yeah
so gravy's coming on that'll be
interesting yes the metaverse episode is
next week on thursday do we know on what
day of the week
it's the uh
we have him oh it's a wednesday 20th
it's
yeah yeah okay
well guys
it's another week together
h3 podcast that's just how the [ __ ] we
do it
short but great next week we're going to
be hopefully doing four episodes if you
include the metaverse
right
and uh that's just how the [ __ ] we do it
here at the h3 podcast live
so thank you to everybody
have a great weekend and we'll see on
monday
have a good weekend
[Music]
oh
[Music]